JK, JK, I'm denying you of this loop.
I'm denying loops.
Sorry.
I had Ah, pastoki.
Why did you have to do?
Oh, I'm on my fucking recording mic.
Give me a sec.
Sorry.
I'm so full.
I go.
I'm, oh, why did I do this to myself?
Pastoki.
I'm so, oh, I'm, I'm all over the place right now.
I, when are you never all over?
That's the secret.
I'm working on the oh, I was sorry my loud.
Okay, I should be better now.
I should be better.
Sorry I was on my recording I was on my recording profile to
record stuff Oh past turkey strikes again.
Sorry.
I've been planning the apex stuff I wish I I wish I worked
on this a lot earlier when I like did the meat of all of
this a lot earlier But I was so out of it and I had so much
other stuff to do I'm, I'm, I'm doing my best.
I'm, okay.
So I'm sending invites right now.
We're like, we're still like finishing up the format.
I can talk about this a bit because like we were supposed to
announce this today, but we didn't really, or yesterday or
today.
I don't know.
But already like, like officially I'm at the Twitter
recruitment tweet.
So okay.
So this is my dilemma right now.
I'm trying to balance in a way so that, because like they're
asking me if I want to include pro players my issue with a
lot of the creator tournaments in the past was that people
find loopholes.
They'll stack their teams in a way where, um, where they'll
stack, they'll stack their teams in a way where, uh,
they're, they're, they're like, you know, they're, they're
like ex-pros, but they haven't been pro for a while.
But then they like be like, yeah, but they're not in a pro
category because they haven't been pro in a while.
And I was just like, yeah, but they have the game sense of
awareness of a pro play.
Like, you know, in the other creator tournaments we've see a
lot so then but then we i'm like we want to make like an
apex slash street fighter collab so like i'm thinking like
well i can't be all just like non-apex players because that
doesn't you know because i know like people would not be
really like the apex side might not like that because um
it's like oh this is a apex event but yet no apex players
are involved in the event so so i'm trying to find a healthy
balance between the two because like i have some street fire
players that are that said yes to joining um but then some
of them haven't really played apex before and so they
obviously the people who have played apex are just gonna
fucking shoot them down and i don't want i want them to have
i don't want them to be in the death screen the entire time
by the way it's for fun game there's some there there are
mandatory game modes where they have to shoot their gun so
so the thing is that um uh we have like melee game mode we
have like a melee game mode okay remember the game mode we
were cooking about the we selected tribute i have that in
like because i think that'll be really fun i hope that'll be
really fun i hope that won't be boring for people just you
know if you're not the tribute you're just watching it the
entire time i'm mostly worried there's like people who are
not beating people up in the boxing ring um they'll find it
boring to just stand there and watch but i'm hoping it'll be
fun to cheer to cheer like cheer on your teammate i don't
know um and i said if you win the 1v1 you have to do a
finisher on them uh because i think it'd be funny you know
because he's like finish him you know i know it's not the
same it's not the same fighting game but it's like you know
the you know they're doing a you're alting you know uh so
they're doing good they're gonna do a low four or some i
don't know um so that's one of the game modes we have hide
and seek we have like the street fighter uh 1v1s yeah i know
i said it's the wrong it's the wrong fighting game but it's
like i think it'll be funny to have a finisher at like they
have to do a finisher or something at the end like whoever
wins the 1v1 they have to do a finisher on him um so so i
have that so we're still finalizing everything but the thing
is originally i was like no pros and no recent Pred players
and they're like how about recent two seasons I was like no
people are gonna abuse that role because people always abuse
that role where they'll find so they're like oh no recent
Preds all right let me get someone that's season like you
know like like um season 25 Pred or some shit you know so
like so I okay I was just like no recent Pred in the last 20
seasons because I was season three and four Pred so I was
like no recent Pred in the last two so I could play Because
I can't be like, no Preds at all.
Because I have a Pred badge.
So I was like, in the last 20 seasons.
So that was, like, the initial idea I had.
But then we were restricting a lot of bigger Apex content
creators.
Or just Apex content creators in general.
And, yeah, I'm making my own loophole.
Yeah, I'm using myself as the reference cutoff.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Doki.
Oh, yeah, nice weekend.
Excited for the rest of the week.
Thank you.
Thank you, Lovachetta.
Super.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I touched.
I'm ended on season.
So, like, touching prayer doesn't count.
Yosh, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Procrastination.
I know.
That's why I know.
It's a problem.
I know.
I'm trying.
But thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Lolly, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Why does Past Doki use?
I don't know.
Past Doki is like, don't worry.
She's got...
I don't got this.
I don't.
That's Doki.
I'm so tired.
Patria, I said to you with Super Chat.
Thank you, Doki.
Since you're finishing only Moosh on your new full
playthrough game, may I recommend a guarantee called Classic
Mascot Platformer Garfield Escape from Monday releasing in
two days.
What the fuck?
As a Garfield fan, I must check out what this is.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Maybe.
Maybe we'll do it on Halloween.
I don't know.
Maybe it'll be something we play on Halloween.
Anyway, but then like, okay, now there's a little dilemma.
So I'm trying to, so I got some Tree Fighter people sort of,
I don't want to say them out because I don't know maybe a
little, it's like, you know, because they'll be like, Toki,
this is so last minute.
It's like, I know.
And so I'm like converting players today.
And they're like, Toki, this is a little really, I was like,
I know, I'm sorry.
like I I know like we don't even have everything fully
confirmed but we have the game modes confirmed it's just we
have the prize money distribution confirmed so um so it's
like first to fourth place each game mode would get prize
money and everyone will have street fighter skins they can't
unlock all the street fighter skins but they can unlock most
of the street fighter skins so most of the ones that they
want to unlock um unfortunately we won't be we weren't able
to provide all of it but just majority of it so for free for
every participant that's something I specifically because I
know a lot of other tournaments, they don't have that.
A lot of the creator tournaments.
But I was like, if you're trying to promote the Street
Fighter skins, it makes sense to participants should be able
to use the Street Fighter skins in the tournament to
showcase it too.
So I was able to, because, you know, in the other creator
tournaments I've done, I didn't get any coins or anything,
any free skins.
But I was able to convince EA slash Apex of each other to
them for putting out with me in their patience can provide
free apex coins like they don't even have to spend like but
like it would be encouraged that they use the apex coins to
unlock the street fighter skins so they can use it on stream
like it would be highly i think i can't force them like it's
like you can't participate unless you spend that coin on
apex skins like like if i don't see you i'm a street fighter
skin you're out
um anyway so um so i just my dilemma right now so i'm you
know i actually didn't not sleep that much i did not sleep
uh that much today uh i actually went to bed at like 11 a.m
because i was working on the apex stuff i was other i was
working on a lot of other things not just apex there's a lot
of other stuff going on behind the back burner um and yeah i
took a nap between 11 and i Oh my god, Dad, I fed Dad.
By the way, he's been fed.
He even got a little treat before his stream.
Anyway, so this is my little dilemma.
Because I'm like, I feel like I should not, like, close the
door on, like, pros and Apex content creators.
Because I think it would be better if it's, like, actually
the Street Fighter and the Apex creators.
Like, you know, because it's a crossover.
Like, you know, Apex Street Fighter.
If, because, uh, if they can actually participate.
So, like, my idea initially, I.
propose this idea um is that we uh we assign each team at
least like one pro slash uh apex content creator but the
thing is they're not allowed to use their guns and i like so
so it's like it's like a subversion you know the fps player
has to use their hands and that has to use melee and then
the fighting game player has to use the gun so it's like a
little subversion you know but then fun for the apex
streamer you know for an apex viewer slash streamer would
that be fun if their favorite apex content creator isn't
allowed to shoot their gun like yeah yeah i'm just like i'm
just like that's what i'm worried about also mara thank you
for the uh thank you thank you for the raid thank you thank
you so i'm like whoa like so so i'm like would that be to
the average apex viewer if um if you know oh my god he's so
why why why okay give me a sec
all right he literally he literally already got his treat
and he actually just left a little bit of food just to like
uh i should have left a little bit of food um before i
started the stream but i've given him all the food before
the stream because i was like okay well he's he's hung he's
already you know his belly full before the stream starts but
he doesn't care he uses this to take advantage of the fact
that you get more food and like i actually don't have any
more food and i already gave him a treat before stream too
just to make sure just to be like maybe i'll give him his
food and his treat so he knows that like you know the
routine's done like like it's that you already got
everything and then now he's like but what if i can get more
but the thing is there is no more.
Dad, there's no more.
I, you know what I did?
I took, I took, I got the empty can and I put it in his food
bowl.
So I'm like, there's no more.
I like, I put the, I put the empty can in the food bowl and
I'm like, there's no more.
You ate it all.
Throbbing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for missing your table.
The best.
Expo May Cafe.
And as you ask, I'll get that Doki tramp stamp tattoo.
Thank you.
Super chat, Throbbing Wizard.
For those who don't know, Wizard has an arm sleeve of all
Doki tattoos.
And then he asked me, like, what other tattoo you should put
on his arm.
And then I was like, well, obviously the wonder you're
missing one very important Doki to complete your collection.
And it's sexy Doki.
So Doki, why would you do that to what do you mean?
Or you'll get all the ladies for this trust me um but the
thing is he was like well i was planning on getting a tramp
stamp too so i was like oh yeah no sexy dokey for that no so
he's gonna be getting a um he's gonna be getting a sexy
dokey tramp stamp and don't die i think he'll i think he's
gonna catch all the ladies with that tattoo all right is
that it is permanent yes end and I think it would increase
his game I think the the sheer sexiness of sexy dokey is
gonna level him up that's how you become a real wizard and
that's yeah that's how I met my wife it's like you want to
see my sexy dokey tramp stamp it's a story there's a story
there guys uh there is a story to it um anyway so yeah so
this is like my current conundrum right now because i'm like
okay if i do make it so that it's um if i do make it so that
it's like you know uh if i like open the gates to like apex
streamers and apex bros uh but like i'm gonna restrict each
team to have one just one um and but the thing is Like I
said, would it be fun to the average Apex viewer to watch
their favorite shooter streamer, like, you know, shooter
game streamer, not shoot their gun?
And that's what I'm, I'm like, I don't know.
I might be overthinking it, but I always, I do, I just,
dude, dude, guys, bros, homies.
Dude, dude, dude.
I'm sorry.
Like, would, would they enjoy watching that?
Like, that's, My biggest problem right now, trying to,
because I know, like, you can't make everyone happy, but I
don't want it to be a poor experience for a lot of people.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't want, I don't want it to, because I noticed, like,
you know, like, you know, I'm trying to make it so that the
newer players, because we have newer Street Fighter players
who are newer at the game as well, uh who are newer at the
game and i don't want them to get like fucking hunted down
like like it's like a duck season like yeah so so i don't
want them to have get like hunted down and it doesn't matter
what because what guns the pro players or the apex players
will have in general because no matter what they're just
gonna fucking kill the entire lobby because of the different
skill Yeah, I don't want it to be like rabbit season.
so like, that's why I'm like, I, and the thing is, what I've
learned too from other tournaments, you know, like Rivals
tournaments and other tournaments I've participated in, it's
not fun seeing your favorite streamer get destroyed if
they're newer at the game and don't play the game as well.
Like, remember, like, there's some like Rival tournaments
where they invite streamers who have never really played
Rivals before and they're stuck on like, you know, they're
put on Raccoon Duty or like they just don't know what
they're doing.
And then they're losing every game because they don't know
what they're doing and they're losing every game because
they don't know what they're doing and uh it's not fun to
watch as a viewer so i don't want and you know in apex
there's the death screen too so i don't want people to be
like to always see their favorite streamer especially in
street fighter because i'm trying to encourage more like
street fighter viewership uh to look at apex because you
know we're trying to attract people who are who might not uh
who might not uh play apex uh to want to download apex as
well so uh so like an overlap of like player base and stuff
and so i'm i'm you know i'm just like thinking about all of
this and just being like uh what would make you a more
enjoyable experience to watch i might i might put a
recruitment post later on i don't know if i should wait for
permission to post the recruitment post um but if i don't
gonna um i'm uh i might just tweet it out because i feel
like i already announced it so i already announced anything
and but the thing is i have not confirmed because like i'm i
i'd rather just not give the pro players slash pred players
any form of shooting ability i i would prefer that because
i'm like would they have fun like with the viewer because
Like, would the Apex viewers have fun watching them fucking
just punching shit?
Like, or get, I don't know, get gunned down by Street
Fighter players.
Like, yes, but I don't want, the thing is, I don't want Apex
viewers to also not enjoy the experience as well.
So, it's like, it's hard.
You know, it's very hard.
Because, like I said, I don't want the Apex viewers.
Like, the pros can tank it.
They've taken worse shit.
Like, I mean, I mean, we can all agree that, like, Apex,
like, esport in general for Apex, it's like, it's very,
like, I won't say brutal, but, like, because there's 20
teams, you know, per turn.
teams can qualify and then your their fates it's decided by
the ring and sometimes players don't predict the ring
properly it's decided by the ring and the outside factor a
lot of outside a lot of RNG slash outside factor they've
taken worse like so yeah it's very it's yeah so um so like
you This one tournament won't fucking break a pro player's
mental.
It won't break their fucking mental.
But I'm more concerned about the Apex viewership.
Because, you know, we're trying to promote Street Fighter.
And we're trying to promote the Street Fighter collab skins.
And, you know, Apex viewers play the game a lot.
And, you know, they might buy these Street Fighter skins.
You know, seeing how cool it looks.
I'm like thinking like, okay, like...
What would be enjoyable for the apex viewer When they're
watching their favorite pro or favorite apex creator Would
that be enjoyable for them to watch that they can't use
their gun
So I'm trying to like do like a I don't know do like a
between the two and so that's what's very difficult right
now for me because i'm originally i was like no pros or no
recent threads and i'm just i'm trying to i'm now i'm like
debating whether or not should lift that and be more because
like be more uh be more like lenient on that and just be
like yeah i got compromised somewhere and the thing is i
feel really bad because i had like a whole debate with like
one the uh staff member like yeah but we shouldn't do that
because we were gonna find lupos and like i don't want
people to get i don't know if i want like but i'm like you
know i'm already walking back on it being like okay but what
we do allow them because i had a huge debate with one staff
being like i don't know if this is good because the street
fighter players they'll feel like they're getting absolutely
demolished and then um and also like i want to but then i'm
like yeah but then i'm like thinking okay maybe we can make
it a way where the uh where the player won't actually like
where the play where like the good players won't destroy
everyone else by just nerfing them to shit like just giving
them no gun all they have Is there movement and melee like
like I said, it's very complicated.
I have to finalize everything by the end of today Basically,
I have to figure out what I'm looking for by the end of
today So so I'm just yeah Like you can't like yeah, you're
right you can't satisfy everyone You can't satisfy everyone
you can't make everyone happy but I want to do my best to as
fun as possible and as enjoyable as a viewer experience as
well as for new players to not get absolutely destroyed
yeah so uh because then if also yeah so like there's that uh
um so i'm you know i'm i'm thinking about it because if we
are doing that then i'll have to sign a pro slash content
creator to each team as well like i'll sign it like the big
the pros because the thing is what i realized is the pros
slash um slash apex trainers that like create the teams in
the previous tournaments and obviously they want to win they
want to win a lot of money it's 30 grand but it's 30 grand
split between five games so like you know also i made a rule
that if you win first place you can't win again you can't
like so like they won't farm it you know they won't farm
like oh i'll have to make the best team possible and then
just keep farming first place um because it is five games
split between so i made it so that if they they can't win
first place um non-stop like like if they won first place
already they can't do it again but that didn't want to be
but then they'll be like oh what's the point if i already
win i won't be able to get money after that so so second
third fourth sorry second third fourth is still um it's
still up in the air they can still grab second third or
fourth they just can't farm first place um so i added that
rule in so they get first they just can't like take any of
the money like they can't be even being they can't be placed
second or anything it's just no money for you um and so and
it's going to be 10 teams it's not going to be the wildcard
mode the newest wildcard mode for street fighter um so uh
less people to find thank god less less people to recruit oh
thank goodness yeah i don't have to worry about that like um
and i don't know i'm just i i don't know i hope i'm I'm
just, I'm just worried that people, uh, I'm just worried
that, you know, since I wish I did start planning this a lot
earlier because I, like I said, I couldn't start planning
until like, I think like two days ago, two to three days
ago.
There were so many things going on and a lot of other stuff
in the, so like it, I knew I should have like put this in
motion a lot earlier, but like I had so much stuff going on.
and i sent out recruitment stuff today like like today and
yesterday uh i sent in recruitment stuff today and yesterday
so uh so i'm hoping i'm hoping to i already got
confirmations on some players uh and uh yeah so like i said
by the end of today i have to figure out if i want to what
wait okay what do you guys think do you think if i remove
the pro slash apex creators ability to shoot their gun do
you think they will have a good time or are they going to
complain 24 7 or more so or the apex viewer if um do you
think the apex viewer would complain about the fact that
they aren't able to shoot their gun and it makes it a worse
experience uh for a viewer to watch
well the thing is they they have to willingly consent to
being a tournament so they know in advance that they won't
be able to use your gun if they participate in this
tournament that's the thing if they like you know like you
can't have your cake and like you can't have like this and
also like that so like it's not Like, we're going to be
like, whoa, JK, you can use your gun now.
But,
so, yeah, but, like, I just need to know, like, as an, as an
Apex viewer, if you watch your favorite Apex streamer, not
be able to, not be able to shoot their gun.
Would you enjoy watching that?
because I could add a game mode, an extra game mode where
they're allowed to shoot their gun, but they get one gun or
some shit.
I don't fucking know.
Like, I...
What are they... I mean, I'll be like, you can have one gun,
but it has to be like, I don't know, peach one.
I don't know.
What's the shittiest gun right now in Apex Legends?
I don't fucking know.
I don't even know what's the shittiest uh oh okay I have I
do have an idea we put all the pros as solos oh my wait a
minute okay all okay we could do it where all the pros and
the Apex kind of creators they leave their teams and they're
all solos and then and against everyone else like well
everyone else will still be playing against everyone we
could do that We can't have a game mode.
But there's just be one game mode where we separate.
So they can, like, the pro slash comic creators would just
be solo and they can only have one gun.
They can only have one gun.
And so, but they'll just be hunting the street fighter.
Not gonna lie, they'll just be hunting the street fighter.
But I'll be like, I'll be like, anyone that's not a solo.
You might, you are allowed to work.
allowed to team with other teams, but then it's also risky
because you don't know who's the solo and who's not.
Like, so cute.
So I'm like, okay, it's a little bit scary because like, um,
because like, if you're, I was like, you're allowed to like
team people, people, but then the thing is like, you don't
know which one's the solo.
You might actually shoot your, your teammate.
yeah i don't have so i don't know how i'm honored that um
yeah so like solos versus two news might not be like the
best i i don't know i don't know so like i think we could
make it so like all like if you're above if you got like
you're above masters we put because it's 10 teams right so
like we could technically remove one player to be a solo as
well uh so like there people yeah that's oh that's the thing
you do as a chest chat the first gun they finally have to
use it duck they give the super chat they can think i could
do that but then it's so rng of yes they give a super chat
they can thank you you could make the pros they can reload
after grab a new gun or make their shots count that would
that would be fun that would be a good idea we could have
but that would be like one i would assume i would rather
that be like that could be like one game one game mode we
could have that i'll just actually write this down too
that's actually good um but then it's more so it's like will
they would would they be okay with that
Because, like, one of my game mode is Protect the Princess.
It's Protect the Princess.
And, well, the pros should know better, you know.
They should be, they should know better than to lie.
You know what I'm saying?
They should know better than to lie.
Because they know how the game is played.
Like, yeah.
um and um because i do have protect the princess you know
that because i like i think that game mode is very funny and
it's like the highest ranked player or is will be the
princess and the new people have to protect them and the
highest rank player can't use anything except they can they
can use their fists and their abilities that's it and um but
then i'm like oh what if we yeah i think that game mode is a
very fun so i could maybe add another i could add one more
game mode where okay so there is a normal wildcard match and
then i can make it so that the wildcard match the pros or
the good apex grade like if you're a regular apex creator
you can't read if you're like masters plus you can't or pred
or what i mean i think i should be like pred or pro you
can't reload and have that to grab a new gun or make your
shots count yeah i'd like that i think that's a good idea
I'll put that rule in there and then I'll maybe I'll lift
the restrictions about it I don't know maybe I'll make a
tweet right now actually I'm gonna make a tweet right now um
uh let's see oh yeah in Doki News Network there's actually
like nothing really exciting to I don't know the last couple
days haven't been really fun like not fun but I haven't been
really exciting in terms of like Doki News Network.
Are there... Okay, there is two very exciting news.
Well, not very exciting.
But more so, more so of the fact that so technically,
Blizzard, welcome to Doki News Network where all the news
you hear right now is 100% true unless there's a community
note three hours later.
Anyway, so Blizzard slash Activision now currently owns Halo
and they also fired a bunch of people
so for those who don't know yeah so they basically fired a
bunch of people in Halo and then they relocated the the team
to well they've relocated is basically activision is
officially taking over halo so like it's gonna be a new team
going into halo now so that's gonna be interesting uh we'll
we'll see how that's good yeah ducky that's not funny yeah i
was like i was like well not really exciting news um so i
guess we'll see how that goes because it's the same team
that made call of duty So, yeah, so the same team that made
Call of Duty is going to be working on Halo now.
So we'll see how that goes.
On other news, on Doki News Network, apparently one of the
strongest Wi-Fi routers out there at the moment for a good
budget, for a good price, is a minion router.
So apparently, well, I actually was tempted to buy it, but
the moment that tweet went viral, you cannot get that shit
anymore for cheap.
You can't even get that for cheap anymore.
Y 'all scooped it up.
Everyone scooped up the minion router.
Oh, no.
So, yes, apparently, it's one of the best possible Wi-Fi 6E
routers money can buy for just $80.
after the tweet went viral it's no longer the most
affordable wi-fi router out there the pokemon scalpers got
him they actually did i will not be surprised somebody
fucking programmed to bot and bought all the fucking minion
routers so apparently this is the most affordable budget
friendly uh best wi-fi router that you can get right now
yeah like um i don't know i i don't even know what to say i
yeah it was the most affordable wi-fi router it this is not
my address by the way i got this i don't know where the this
person lives this i got this from the twitter screenshot so
apparently this is what What it looks like.
Let's see.
But yeah, apparently for all you router nerds out there.
I don't know if this is like porn for you guys.
But I don't know if this does anything for you guys.
But apparently for those who know tech, if they see it,
like, oh my gosh.
God, whoa, what a heat, whoa, look at, look at those cards
in those holes.
Oh, fuck, that compression, oh, I, yeah, that's so indecent,
oh my God, yeah, any IT professionals right now?
out groaning at this.
I... Me!
I'm doing it right now.
Alright, well, you could keep that to yourself, but...
The cooling.
Damn, look how snatched those chips are.
I...
Give me a minute.
Give me...
Oh, wow!
Wow, there!
Um...
Me a drooling k-man when it comes to tech i like your funny
words magic bird gordon thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you jacquarder they give a super chat thank you
thank you the halo situation is kind of catch-22 since many
folks were on board with what 343 halo studio has been doing
the last couple of years and then asking for a change and
then they got the god team they give us super chat thank you
thank you so yeah we'll we'll see how that one goes um i
guess that's really like i said uh for first time not a lot
of like super like uh big news um has uh really popped up
the last couple of days uh i mean did i write wrote anything
let me let's see did i write anything uh nope yeah oh yeah i
guess saturday night live is now there's do you guys know
there's a uk version of saturday night live i was not aware
of that i popped up in my like youtube algorithm i was like
these aren't the cast members why are they all british yeah
there's apparently a saturday night live um there's a
saturday night live british version yeah there's a he made a
british version of yeah i did not realize that uh so a
little fun fact a little fun fact and also uh the If you
guys watch like, uh, I guess like American high school or
college or whatever, all those different types of, um, you
know, like those comedy skits, they were, for the new Silent
Night Live cast, they recruited one of the more famous cast
members from the American high school YouTube channel.
Her name's Grace, I think.
Her name is Grace, and, uh, everyone's like freaking out
about it, but I feel really bad for her.
By the way, have you ever watched like the, I don't know,
what was it?
What the, what's that?
movie that she like long video she made the real the i think
it was called like um the real hunger games or something i
know some of you guys might not be like why do you why do
you keep up with oh yeah the hunger games but better grace
writer whatever uh that's her name yeah grace writer um
everyone's i saw my twitter i actually low-key actually
enjoy saturday night live enjoy Saturday Night Live.
I'm sorry.
I'm like, yeah, don't keep, not you.
But I low-key, unironically do enjoy Saturday Night Live.
Because sometimes they have, sometimes they have bangers.
I don't know.
Sometimes they, they get better at some of the, some of them
might be good.
Also, I realized my OLED monitor is going to go into like
OLED mode very soon.
start the game yet so give me 10 more minutes guys give me
yeah like when it hits it hits anyway so everybody's
freaking out about this this new cast member her name is
grace writer because she has a very uh she has a good
portfolio online where it comes to content creation because
she's like a big con she's basically like a skit creator on
youtube and she has like you know like not like she has
videos that has had millions of views and stuff um and she's
like the first person I think to get recruited into Saturday
Night Live I believe I think she's like the first she's the
first Gen Zer to be on Saturday Night Live and and um um but
then everybody's freaking out about like I saw so many
people talking about it on my Twitter algorithm being like
oh she's gonna she's gonna be a star um she's gonna be a
star she's gonna like like be like the next big
like okay now that well like now there's so much pressure on
her you know now there's so much pressure on her to nail the
first episode like the the season opener and season premiere
because if she's not funny in the season premiere then like
every yeah there's so much pressure Because she's like,
everyone's like, oh, wow, you actually recruit a funny
person this time.
I'm like, bro, like, bro, like, what if she's not funny in
the season premiere?
Because it's all dependent.
It's all dependent on the writers, the fucking sketch
writers.
And also, like, in the moment shit.
So I'm, we're going to see if she's going to crack, I guess.
We're going to see if she's going to be funny.
like yeah and so it really heavily depends depends on if
they if she's lucky and gets a good script or good scene and
then she's also a new cast member too so usually new cast
members don't get a lot of scenes um in the beginning of
saturday night live so like because you know they're new
they're new players they're new like they're new cast
members so obviously they have to share the responsibility
like they have to they have to like um still fight for like
scenes to do within the compared to the other cast members
so it's like you know sorry it's like i actually
unironically do watch saturday night live because i i love
certain oh there's some hosts that love watching uh whenever
they get uh invited to i will say i'm sorry i'm not a fan of
jack black hosting saturday night live because they like
it's just like he's a funny person but i don't think he's
funny on saturday night live like yeah yeah i don't i don't
think he's funny on saturday night live i think like i don't
know maybe the skits are terrible for him maybe he gets the
worst fucking skits handed to him um in snl but like every
time i've seen him host it's not funny like
I don't know the skits are just I they're either poorly
written or some shit or just like they don't play to his
strengths so like that's like one of my like you know it
just depends on the host I think um I okay I love when
stand-up comedians uh when stand-up comedians get to host I
think one of my favorite um oh my god what was it what am I
because they're like so I don't I love it when stand-up
comedians host snl because they you know they know the
formula what can be funny and they are like they're also
like they're good at playing the straight man too i think
that's what i love about like um i think like comedy actors
versus stand-up comedians when they get snl is that stand-up
comedians they tend to play the straight man or they're like
they're just they're very serious but they say the most
ridiculous shit like they say the craziest shit But they
are, like, so serious about it.
But if you get comedians doing SNL, yeah, if you do
comedians doing SNL, it's, like, more so they play, like,
wacky characters or something, like, wacky, silly
characters.
And it's, like, sometimes I feel like it's just trying a
little too hard.
Other than, okay, there is one comedian after that I fucking
love.
What's her name?
Whenever she gets SNL.
uh she's the one that did spencer uh when they do the like
the politics segments uh
uh oh what's her name she's so funny i love everything she
does i think she has a comedian is really i i know i love i
love comedy i love comedians i think comedians are like one
and more smart like i think comedians are like very smart
people melissa mccarthy i fucking love Melissa McCarthy.
I'm sorry, we're doing like normie talk right now, um,
because like my OLED monitor needs to update and I don't
want to be in a random in the middle of a boss fight and
then my monitor shuts down.
So I'm like stalling here.
Um, I fucking love Melissa McCarthy.
I think Melissa McCarthy is incredibly funny.
Um, and like, I think like really good comedians, I think
are
joke or being funny is surprisingly very hard it's very hard
to like be funny funny in terms of like to the general
public because um being able to set up a joke being able to
play with the joke being able to uh uh you know run with the
bit and just improvving it like on the fly and everything i
think it's a yeah i think it's like a talent and also like
you have to be really smart with it too being able to be
funny like especially writing jokes too it's very hard to
write a good joke like like um because you know sometimes
like goof might think it's funny but is it funnier it's it
funny when it's like to the general public um that's why
like i like i don't i like a lot everyone knows this but in
the original Simpsons writers room it was mostly Harvard
Stanford graduates in the writing room like Conan is a I
think it's a I know she's an Ivy League student he was a he
was in an Ivy League school and um the original Simpsons
what made the original Simpsons so successful is because the
writers room was actually majority also Futurama writers I
fucking love Futurama I can't believe it was like called
classic when it first came out I think Futurama is smartest
like animated comedies that ever came out um yeah kona is a
harvard alumni and a lot of the original uh a lot of the
original uh writers in like peak simpsons peak futurama or
like um and uh like just like especially comedy shows are
usually the writers in the past i don't know about current
but like in the past um it's usually the writers are Ivy
League alumni, like Harvard, Stanford, Oxford, like, they're
all like alumni from um, uh, from like, uh, you know, alumni
graduates.
So, so it's, it's like, it's very interesting.
I think like, I just, I just personally think like a lot of
like good comedians, a lot of good stand-up comedians, a lot
of good comedians are very smart people in general, just
because I think it takes a lot of um it takes a lot of like
i guess like especially making a joke that's uh that appeals
to the overall general public you know it's not just like oh
it's a smart joke that only smart people can understand it's
a joke that not only it appeals to everyone everyone in
overall in terms of like yeah um it can appeals to people
who are smart it appeals people who are like you know,
average, or below average, or above average, like, you know,
um, it, like, it's just a general appeal and everything.
Uh, me, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, y'all make a joke that everyone can understand.
Um, uh, why was the paper so strong?
Because it was ripped.
Me, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Kuka, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, jokes rated E for everyone.
Um, this is why I love watching I love watching stand-up
comedy and I love watching comedy shows because I you know I
I I rarely watch drama or like uh like very serious shows
because I'm already stressed out
I I'm already stressed out like and I don't need more I
don't want like you know absorbing stress from shows even
though it's like it's not real Toki but it's like yeah but
like I still anxiety and stuff of like watching more serious
shows so i rather just like relax i rather i rather just
relax and like and watch a show that i can um enjoy without
being stressed out about i just need something to like turn
off like there are some shows that watch are more intense in
general but it's like actually when when what show no it's
been a while while.
I'm like trying to think of one.
I don't know.
I'm watching Modern Family right now.
Uh, Kuka, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Um, is it funny things such highly educated people were
responsible for bringing us so many fart jokes?
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know if that's true, though.
I don't, I, I think, well, for me, I personally don't like,
I don't like gross humor at all.
okay i for my type of humor i don't like gross humor and i
don't like secondhand embarrassing cringe humor i actually
turn i actually look away or skip i'm watch if i'm watching
from a stream like if i'm watching a streaming service if
there's cringe humor where like someone is obviously trying
to be as make someone as uncomfortable as possible or make
them like you know obviously you're like oh i want to i'm
going to look away like i actually will look away i would
skip i'll skip the scene yeah it's just that's too much i i
don't care if it's not real i just don't like that feeling i
i oh i hate that a lot yeah cyber thank you for super chat
thank you thank you not too fun a super serious material so
we should not expect the playthrough of drinking guard one
huh cyber thank you with super chat thank you thank you well
it's i don't gaming is show because it requires me to sit
there and watch it so like i like if i'm you know i'm not
interacting with a show i'm watching so um yeah so like
gaming i could do serious games and everything i'm really
you know while i was like doing my schedule i was like
thinking like
um thinking about like i wonder there's like you know silent
hills the new silent hill games coming out this week i'm not
gonna play it uh but i do wonder if it'll be good because
like i haven't heard anything about it yet the game's coming
out this week and it's it's always worrying it's always
worrying some when you don't hear about a upcoming uh
upcoming triple a title game like nothing so i do i i hope
it's good i don't know oh it's out it's out already oh my
god okay it's apparently good okay okay i don't even realize
it was out already i didn't oh it's out early oh yeah they
do the pre-order early release yeah okay i get it all right
so i'm not gonna play it because like silent hill is very
like i i'm just too stressed out about silent hill is scary
scary um it's a yeah it's a bit scary okay then it's gonna
be scary scary for me when i played silent hill 2 i was not
okay i legitimately had to stop i could only play the game
maximum two hours i cannot i cannot i literally my heart was
beating every time i played uh every time i played silent
hill 2 i legit i can't do it i i don't know if i can do it
again.
Lani, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
To quote Yatsu, what they failed to realize is that
deliberately annoying is still annoying.
The same applies to cringe.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, so yeah.
Also, my monitor's doing the reset right now.
I'm waiting.
It's just a black screen right now.
Sorry.
I know this was a one hour hangout.
They're like, Doki, start the game!
I'm sorry.
There was just a lot of stuff going on.
A lot of stuff I need to talk about and word vomit.
A lot of things I needed to like, what's the word?
I need to yapp about and let out.
Yeah, so much yapp and technical stuff.
I still need to tweet out about the Apex stuff.
So, yeah, it's, oh my gosh, my monitor's still there.
My monitor still hasn't finished old editing right now.
What else?
What else is going on in Miss Jokey Bird's life?
I mean, that's really it.
I've been just mostly planning all of this.
Like I said, every time I feel like the, every time I feel
like I'm finished something that's contracted, like I have
another contracted obligation to do that pops up like every
time I thought back after Vexpo I'm on it's done and then
another con like you know I have I then I don't now I have
to organize the apex stuff um so it's like oh man it's busy
busy busy oh yes before let's see it's chill time uh for
those who don't know the gina draw sloppy collection it's
ending this week so make sure to check out the sloppy
sisters collection before it's gone gone yeah but then i
want to work on personal projects i really want to work on
personal projects so badly like i've been i've been itching
to do that but the thing is i can't do that and also the
contracted obligations because i like to put all my full
effort and full focus on contracted stuff uh just to make
sure it comes out good but like I can't it's you know it's
like it it you know um it's a big opportunity and stuff too
so like obviously I would love to do it I would love to do
it um but yeah no I'm I miss doing personal projects too as
well I did told my manager I want to do less contracted
obligation which also by the way guys it might mean less
conventions less conventions, less musical stuff, music
stuff overall and everything because I'm getting overworked
with a lot of them and I personally like you know I think
this year is my music arc I guess like because I've been
doing a lot of music stuff so I think next year I want to do
less music things I like I I want to do his music stuff is
what stresses me out not stress I But I'm not really a music
idol music person, like in terms of like, I'm not really
like, you know, I guess my skill set is my is not my
strongest skill set in terms of like music things.
So, yeah, so it's like, because I know I'm not the best
singer, you know, I'm not the best singer.
a lot of singing opportunities.
And I want to I want to be more picky about them for sure.
I want to be more picky on singing opportunities because I'm
tired.
I'm tired and I want to work on I want to work on personal
projects and more gaming stuff.
We're all like tournaments I know mine organized I think
like because it fits my demographic too like gaming
tournaments and stuff um like and I want to I want to shift
back to events because this year like I know my manager's
like trying to get me like really cool opportunities because
this year he wanted me to focus on music a lot more this
year um and uh I did it
I tried it out, you know, I, I tried it out in my, like a
mute, a semi, like for a year.
And, um, and, uh, and next year, I want to do less of that.
I want to try, I want to focus on personal projects again.
Um, I had fun.
I had fun doing music stuff because I feel like, um, not a
lot of VTubers, they always focus on Japanese songs.
And I feel like I'm one of few that, because I know I sing
Japanese.
songs very poorly because I'm very bad at singing in
So there's more so I'm just trying to play to my strengths
because at least I can sing in English at like to well to an
extent at least I can sort of sing in English.
So I like I like uh you know I like singing songs in English
and I like uh I like um um like being able to provide that
for you guys.
Yeah um anyway but yeah that's really everything i want to
talk about i mean i yeah i do have the wildcard club and
stuff but like more so be like you know future projects i
take in i want to focus less like if you know um i'm
definitely gonna be a bit more picky on terms of like music
projects does it take a lot of me too like for future music
projects not like ones i'm currently doing
yeah like i did tell my manager like these are like the
goals like i was like i'm very i i would like less i don't
know i would like less of these certain think activities and
i want i want more gaming sponsors i would like more gaming
sponsors and i like more gaming stuff i want to go back to
my roots i want a game i just i i just want i want a game i
I want to play video games.
I'm a gamer.
All right.
Let's see.
Make sure to check out the collection ends.
It ends this week.
Girl just wants to play video games.
True.
Plus one.
Upvote.
Updutes.
You get an updutes.
from me oh yeah okay let me um okay um to celebrate the apex
street fighter x street fighter collab apex has reached out
to me to organize a tournament on the 25th i'm current um
it's a bit last minute it is it is a bit last minute but
let's make something super fun together each game each game
will be its own prize pool a third okay a 30k tournament on
a 20 own prize pool and we're still finalizing these things
these things few things is a bit let's make something super
fun to get okay to celebrate the apex tree fighter collab it
has reached out to me to organize a 30k tournament on the
25th uh final 36 new things i'm i want to make it a
crossover a crossover between the fighting game community
and the shooter in the fps fighting game and fps game
community and still currently recruiting players the last
minute let's make something fun together if you're
interested feel free to comment to comment or DM I don't
know if I should do DM I feel like it's spammed but then I
always I do DM in case people well the thing is awesome So,
like, that's the biggest issue because it was so last
minute.
A lot of people couldn't make it.
So, I had, like, yeah, but then I wanted to DM only because
some people just don't want to reply below and they want to
be private about it and DM.
I'll just fucking do DM.
Also, I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
I'll have it finished writing a tweet, but I'll be right
back.
Hey, bite, gab, space, solid.
forward.
Chicado.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let me finish right in.
Apex has reached out.
Okay.
I'm going to put this on here.
Two things.
So fine.
I want to make a crossover between certain still recurring
players.
If you're interested, feel free.
Each participant.
Participant.
all right so if you want to make it a crossover between
fighting games and between the fighting between fighting and
fps and fps come fighting fighting and fps community
so currently between players slash are you interested feel
for your commentary or is it been last but let's make it
something super fun to get some game modes i think would
include melee only hide and seek protect etc hide and seek
and later or yeah 1v1
um wild card new wild card new wild card new wild card new
wild card um how to make it more fun
Okay.
Some games are called Alien.
If you're interested, feel free to...
However, we are still discussing about balancing stuff.
And there will be nerfs.
Oh, hello!
Wait, who raided?
Hello!
I'm typing a tweet right now.
We have yet to start the game.
We have not started the game yet.
Oh, Phyllis, thank you for the rate.
Thank you, thank you.
We had a good stream.
So, we're doing work talk right now.
Guys, I swear to God, I'm not that serious.
Well, I am a bit sometimes serious when I have to lock it.
But guys, I swear, that's not the...
entire stream i swear i i'm just i'm trying to i'm trying to
write a serious recruitment tweet right now because i'm
organizing apex tournament and like it's literally uh the
apex tournament is like in three days and i'm still
finalizing stuff for it so so clock is ticking tick tock I
swear to God, it's not the normal extreme.
It's just I'm trying my best right now.
I'm trying my best to figure this out.
All right.
Let's see.
All right, let me finish typing this out.
Apex for your show.
If you give me its own, we're still filing the same thing
about Prime Spongebob, so on and all of those.
And we just included made the only highest a new wild card
game mode.
Plus more.
Plus more game mode.
And more.
Okay.
Are you interested?
Feel free comment.
It's been last minute.
Nest your players.
Who are masters.
Plus.
Who are master.
which include which may or may may or may not include being
forced to melee the entire time or or um um sure you know
this has just been both honestly it's been both i i could
have done this a little earlier but there's so many things i
had to pick and choose which one to do prioritize and today
today last two days has been this uh uh so this i'm out of
self and there will be nurse players who are which may or
may not include being forced to melee the entire time or
potentially no reload on gun one gun only so you know what
so you know what you're getting what you're getting yourself
into uh we are fighting um hoping to get out hoping to get
this the tournament will have newer players showcasing uh
especially those from players and i want them to have a
fighting chance To celebrate the Apex Tree Fighter collab,
Apex has reached out to me to organize a 30k tournament on
the 20th.
Each game will be its own prize pool, and we're still
finalizing through things.
But I'm prioritizing fun game modes versus...
I want to make crossover between the fighting game and FPS
community and still current recruiting players.
Some game modes will include melee-only, hide-and-seek, and
new wildcard game mode, and much and more.
If you're interested, feel free to comment or DM DM.
bit last minute so let's make something super fun together
however we're still discussing about balancing stuff and
there will be nursery players who are master splash we may
not include being forced to main entire tab or potentially
one gun only so no you're actually getting stuff into in
this as a tournament will uh will have newer players and
want them to have a oh i said 25th on the 25th this friday
um uh oh wait uh only players from na uk and netherlands i
know it's such it's just ea rules i again participate all
right um it's just an na rule i think it's a battlefly rule
because battlefly has like a partnership with ea in terms of
every turn every curator tournament has to be under
battlefly and they're only restricted to na uk and the
netherlands um i don't know if it's like an e i think it
might be a between with ea and and n battlefly yeah because
like i i asked feisty if feisty could join and then feisty
is not na uh so um and they're like no it's only i felt so
bad but feisty's helping me recruit people too she's helping
me recruit uh uh fighting game players so i really that even
though she couldn't join herself so because she wanted she
was looking forward to like i saw her tweeting about the
street fighter collab and i wanted to invite her to it but
like i said like um she couldn't because like there's a lot
of people i wanted to invite like kony couldn't do it
because it overlapped with an event that he's doing on
friday emily couldn't do it because uh she had a riffbound
event i wanted to invite like you know fredan and emily but
they both have the riffbound like so many things i think
this is why also like the previous creator that was organize
it.
The reason why it was like real, like, you know, I took this
is because the previous creator that was supposed to
organize it had to drop out very last moment as well.
So they're like, Kendochi did this.
And I was just like, oh, like, you know, it's a sponsor.
Like, it's like a sponsor opportunity.
And I was like, yeah, I can do it.
I think I can organize something super quick.
And so I think that's I think that's why I don't think
that's why but like, I didn't realized so maybe like that
creator had something going on that week because i think
maybe that's why they dropped out because i found out that
everything was happening this week alone specifically the
end of like the 20th like the weekend of 25th to like friday
the sunday because there's there's like the new rust
apparently the new rust streamer server is also coming out
on the 24th um yeah the new rest server is coming out on the
24th the streamer rest server so that already limited a lot
of participants uh in general because you know like people
want to stream the rest thing um like the drops and
everything to farm the drops because then 25th would be day
two of the rest event um and people want to farm the drops
and everything and then um and then the 25th apparently is
the riff bound event um that's going on like a big riff
bound event that's going on um so a lot of like the players
i would get for that are fighting game players are also riff
bound players too so a lot of them couldn't do it and then
also apparently there is uh some people just had you know it
was so last minute um it was so last minute it was like the
last minute that like some people just have other
obligations that they have to do on that day and so i'm
trying my best and i'm so i still want a really good
tournament for everybody um but yeah it's just crazy timing
it's just crazy timing over I don't know why the 25th has
everything like like why this week last week could have
that's why can't yeah I'm just like oh my gosh why is
everything releasing this week guys it's like when why can't
we be like GTA 6 where everyone doesn't release everything
on GTA 6 release day like yeah nothing everything nothing
can be rescheduled because everybody decided that this is
the everything this is that week yeah it's so yeah let's see
each came with me its own prize pool yeah everything is just
happening at the end of this week yeah
yeah only Barbie is brave enough to compete against GTA 6
to celebrate apex distribute uh let's see uh so only only
players um any players oh it's not i won't be like i feel
weird be like also always like as if i place the restriction
be like yeah i only will let any players participate in my
tournament also i guess the uk and Netherlands because my
manager is Dutch and so like the Netherlands gets a bone and
I guess the British too because they colonized and it like
it just made me sound like I put the restriction in there
like so I try to figure out the word it'd be like it's not
my control that there is country restrictions like because
it's such a I don't know it's such a weird restriction with
like and the Dutch can play.
Like, it's just a random selection, you know?
I know, that's why it was so...
I felt like it's so random that the Dutch made its way out
of all the European countries.
The Dutch made it in.
Like...
Like, UK, I understand.
Unfortunately, also...
Okay, I just saw, unfortunately, only players from England.
UK every participant will also will also receive and so I
might and have you you fit you've been you fit what have you
been you fit what have you been my staff might might reach
out reach out to you with details yeah let's see I will also
receive um tree fighter collab collab skins for free for
free I think I
happy they were able to accommodate uh all right there you
go
all right I think that's good you just called her revoking
the invitation of Canada to be a member at the extreme
discuracy by Ambassador Let them play Apex.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Alright, there you go.
I did it.
Let's see.
Alright, let me edit this, actually.
And I'm recruiting players right now.
Let's see.
I put in the first set.
sentence so people will know.
A salad, babe.
Apex reached out to me each game.
Alright, let's see.
I put in the first sentence, so when they read the first
sentence, they'll say, oh, she's recruiting players, and I
realized that was one thing I didn't say.
So, alright.
Oh my God, after.
Guys, we might be, we're going to play the game soon, very
soon.
Uh.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
I'm double-checking.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, I think we're good to go um let me pull it up oh
sorry this has been a very long yab session just a lot stuff
going on but i still wanted to stream for you guys uh i
still want to stream for you guys even though we have a very
busy busy busy busy busy week but i still hope you guys
enjoyed my need even if uh even if you know uh we took a
while to start i'm sorry guys no they're shutting down
minion rush breaking news on the dokey news network after 13
years they're planning on shutting down minion rush i should
still have the game on my phone i i haven't played in a
while like i still have it i think it's a good game i think
that game is pretty one not gonna lie all right i was
addicted to that game when it first came out um it's
literally the worst thing it's like when they shut down
what's that game they shut down like what was it that rick
and morney or the simpsons um tap game i can't i think that
sucks especially like a lot of like you know
microtransaction games when they have to shut it down you
know uh i'm literally right now i think it sucks whenever
microtransaction games are shut down because you can you
know someone that spent thousands of dollars on it like no
my rare net flanders uh from episode uh from season 25
episode four no i worked so hard to roll for my that for net
flanders i
Oh, yeah, the pocket morties.
I'm fucking someone spend money.
I know.
Fun vote.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My pocket morty.
Fun fact.
The minion rush game was in hot water.
Yes, your April Fool's prank rerouted all 911 cause.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
Someone died because of minions.
A minion rush.
That's actually crazy to think about.
Someone actually lost their lives.
Alright, let's see.
I know I should have made a more concise.
More concise and straight to a point recruitment post.
But there was just so many things.
I have to say because my tournament is not just a regular
tournament tournament
so yeah it's like I just had to include there's just it's
not it's just not a normal tournament it's not like you you
load it and shoot your gun and check clock out there's a lot
of stuff going on
yeah I gotta warn them in advance
the only i got a little worried about talk saying that the
participants gets free street fighter skins because i'm
worried people be like viewers would be like oh why do they
get free skins but then it's just like yeah because we're
trying to advertise the street fighter like that's the whole
point like if we they have the skin equipped then people
will be like whoa check out the sick skin Like...
It's called marketing!
That's...
Yeah.
Because we want them to have the skins equipped.
This is why...
Okay, this is why I find it weird.
For some, like...
Okay, for some rival...
Rivals tournaments or, like, hero-specific tournaments.
You know, when...
Like, if a new character is...
I'm sorry, I'm still...
You know when new character is announced It doesn't even
have to be rivals But like they make They're like This
tournament is to celebrate the release of this new hero Or
new character But they don't even have it played Because
Yeah Like Like And then they're like Oh yeah Like this
tournament Is to celebrate the new season The newest
character That just came out for this game And then nobody
plays the character because it's a new character and
everyone just wants to win.
Like, they're not like, well, I'm not going to first try
this new character if I'm here to win.
And I always find that so weird in general.
Because they're like, that character's not even meta, so I'm
not even going to try it.
So it's like, what's the point if we're not even showcasing
the new sparkly character?
what's happening here we need to find its source as soon as
possible yeah so that's why i was like well the whole point
is the whole point is to celebrate street fighter be
crossover collab with aphus it would make sense if people
use the street fighter skins instead of us never seeing it
being used like yeah like because we're trying to you know
we're trying we're trying to like um give more publicity the
street fighter the street fighter collab
and i remember one tournament i've done that actually made
it so that you have to play the character but then it was so
bad like not bad but it was so like um hard for the players
because the game literally came out like the new patch came
out like i think like two days ago so like the players that
were stuck on whoever was going to be playing that character
all differ in skill range because some people didn't have
access to the new character in time to learn it that's like
my only gripe about it
all right we're like oh i don't know how long this game is
gonna take me that's for sure what happened here yeah at
least the apex was only skins at least
What a mess
Look out, is it oh it's a new enemy.
I assume the glowing yellow thing is the weak one Because it
wouldn't oh, it's also poison.
Oh
Yep You thought we forgot it's now the poison swamp can now
move Oh, wait, they're babies.
Okay, I don't have to worry about that.
What the fuck?
What did she say?
I didn't hear her.
Oh, my God.
I'm not ready for this, actually.
I'm...
Okay, I was not...
I'm low-key not ready, right?
All right, let's get rid of this guy first.
All right, here we go.
Alright, hello.
Please, please, I'm not ready!
I'm not locked in!
Oh my god, I'm absolutely not locked in right now!
Alright.
There you go.
Oh.
Are you- Oh my god, you- you- okay.
He fucking baited me.
all right that's it yeah that's fucking it don't quit your
day job buddy oh my guy fucked up oh that's right now it's
the time you're the same this is perfection that's right
now's the time
Yeah, he sent!
That's right, get he sent!
Oh my god, I'm doing it.
Wait, what's going on?
Oh shit!
Oh, I got too overconfident!
I was like, oh my god, what's going on?
I'm good, I'm going!
All right, there you go.
Oh shit, no, no, no, no, no, no, not after everything.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Not after everything I bragged about.
All right, there we go.
All right, we're okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
All right.
confidence is a slow killer.
It's a slow, insidious killer.
All right, see?
Nothing to worry about.
Yippee.
All right, nice.
A little lost.
My eyes are so tired right now.
My eyes are heavy.
Mom's spaghetti.
Is it not here?
Where the fuck?
Why did it take me?
Is it just bonus?
Was this just a bonus area?
Like, why the fuck did it take me here?
Oh my god.
Oh, I guess there was...
There must have been...
It must have been blocked by...
The poison must have blocked that area or some shit.
Okay.
That's the only explanation I can think of.
Wait, how do I get over here?
There's literally a chest here.
Am I just... Do I just have to hide myself?
Just need a complete... Oh, no, never mind.
Here we go.
Oh.
Not bad.
Is there anything else here?
No.
Everything's good.
Alright, I can't wait for my back-to-back boss, but...
There must be other plans contributing to it.
Figures.
Okay.
Let's go.
so this place got corrupted what the road's blocked better
turn back what do you mean I sense traces of my people's
power in the area in this big stone area human realm alright
there is some relation to these statues this alright read it
read my wife What?
Glyphs that can be read only by my kind.
Get yourself a wife that can read for you.
When going through hell, one must keep going.
One must keep going.
So never turn back.
Oh shit, I'm already lost.
Never turn back turns back.
All right, this way Read don't know why read when my wife
can read for me right
What's the point that's why I got her
This is a puzzle this is a fucking puzzle isn't it?
Oh my god I guess whichever way the hell one is facing is a
hint Which way is hell?
Which way is hell?
Is this hell?
Is this...
I'm walking?
Alright, give me a second.
Oh, that cat.
I can't think!
Right now.
Don't make me...
I'm gonna grab him.
I'm gonna fucking grab him.
Don't make me do it!
Okay, I'm gonna grab him.
I'm grabbing him.
I'm grabbing it.
Oh, he was.
Oh, you are scared.
You're scared.
Well, weren't you?
Oh.
He has been grabbed.
I have grabbed him.
I've grabbed the dog.
All right.
Oh, my gosh.
He's like me in my fucking mouth.
Let's try and put on my head because I don't have one.
He's two.
Wait, this is like the con.
Unless you have a miniature weiner dog.
There's a con side of having a weiner dog.
dog because like he's so long that my arm has to act as
extension for him like he can't just be on my lap she has to
actually like he has to be uh oh my god he has to use my arm
as an extension for the rest of his body to like lie down on
my like lie down on your lap like you can't have a dog that
just lies on your lap with a weiner dog oh hell is this hell
oh hell Okay, where's he facing?
Here.
Is that not where he was facing?
Oh, here.
Alright, this is hell.
Well, this is technically where hell is facing.
I'm walking.
I'm fucking, I'm fucking walking!
Alright, let's see.
I'm looking at the other stuff.
Okay, Petra from Asura around.
Okay, so this is hell.
It's the one holding the thing.
Did it hit him?
Did it hit the guy that's hell?
Doki, you turned back.
God, okay, fine.
Fine.
Okay.
Okay, okay, well, clearly, clearly I'm not, clearly I'm not
walking very clear.
I, I, I,
okay, I've had it, but my spatial awareness, oh my god, oh
my god, what does that mean?
I'm walking!
Wait, it changed.
Wait, what?
Hell.
The rock was...
an illusion?
Look, I'm very tired, guys.
I'm so tired right now.
It didn't even change.
I just walked the wrong way.
I mean...
Because I'm so tired.
Oh, now you're calm.
You little bitch.
Yeah?
They call now?
Stupid dog.
I'm Mr. Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He's just looking at me right now.
This is what happens when Minion Rush got cast.
You're so right.
I'm still mourning over Minion Rush right now.
I'm still mourning.
I'm in mourning!
Please understand!
Maybe Doki do need the Wolverine loot.
All right.
I'm in mourning right now.
There we go.
Thank you, Oka.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I close my eyes and I can think about his minions.
I expect it will take us to the very heart of the key
sanctuary.
All right, let's go.
Oh, my God.
Serious thing I'm supposed to shoot Okay, are you done?
I'm putting you down On the floor.
I'm on the floor on the floor guys on do not clip me out of
context
No All right, where is it?
All right, there must be something out.
Yeah, I fucking knew it There's always something for me to
shoot Just go and go to a farm upstate, guys.
It'll be fine.
Alright.
What other things do I have to shoot now?
Would I shoot the one below?
Any, uh, any rocks?
Oh, any... Oh, wait, there is.
It's this way.
Take me, not him.
Let him free!
Oh, my God, the game crashed.
came back.
The gate... I was about to... I was about to disassociate.
I was already ready to disassociate there.
I got leaning back ready.
Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm so locked in to be unlocked.
This doesn't look right.
Oh, it does not.
Oh my god, oh my beautiful wife, you're so smart.
What would I do without my beautiful smart wife and her
deductive reasoning?
What?
And her analytical skill.
the stupid man me me just shoot the boat all right here we
go
all right let's see i'll go this way shoot ball brain go
bird dopamine receptor go pew pew pew pew
all right i'll go this way It's better be lore, not a...
Oh, no, there's a lot of heals there.
No, this is not lore.
Oh, unless...
Unless...
She's the brain, I'm the brain.
We're a matchman in heaven.
Examine.
Oh, yeah, funny story.
Um...
used to get sucked around like this they like kicked
everyone i don't know if they shut down the new the okay so
new challengers discord server or they kicked everyone out
because you're planning something else right now and they
want to make clean slate it but i didn't realize that i was
not discord friends with a lot of my teammates because we
shared mutual servers so i always like i like heavily rely
on the mutual servers thing i i always forget to add people
on discord so i never realized that the moment the mutual
server is gone i have no way of communicating with people
like so i was like messaging feisty and nearly i was like
you can't message feisty because you don't have share my
mutual server and i was just like what i was so confused i
was like what do you mean and i'm like oh my god we were
never discord friends we just we were just we just had
mutual server i was like whoops and then she was like i
didn't even notice that either all right
So I thought it was really funny.
I always just rely on the fact that we're just mutual
servers.
It's just convenient.
I just don't remember to send friend requests sometimes.
Because I'm like, if I can message you right now, like, does
it really matter?
You know?
What a mess.
Wasn't this the strongest key sanctuary?
Malice has engulfed it entirely.
This many plants.
And so, I always forget to.
I always forget to add people up because of it.
What the fuck?
Just chill in there.
I did not...
I like...
I did not realize there was a guy there.
Alright, it's a five.
I mean, what's he gonna do?
Actually, nothing.
I need to run into fire.
Nerd.
Yeah, I just forgot I didn't realize it.
Just like a little whoopsie
All right, get that get that shit out of your mouth not for
you That doesn't belong to you
Yeah, I want to go this way Where's the tree?
Oh Oh, there it is why don't target?
Wait, where is the tree?
How do I get up there?
Excuse me.
How do I...
Okay.
I'm your god.
Oh my god.
Surprise.
All right.
What's the point of doing that?
That was fun.
I don't think I can get up there.
I think I have to...
Yeah, there's like...
I think it's on the...
It has to be on...
Is it on the other side?
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Is there...
Is that one...
Wait.
There's stuff up...
here, too.
Oh.
There's like no climbing thing, though.
There's like some... There's obviously a way to get up here.
There's nothing to climb.
I assume that...
I assume there's a way on the other side.
I'm just gonna believe in that.
Yeah, I was gonna say, there's probably a way to go around.
Let me check.
Yeah, it's like here.
I do it from here and here.
I'm just going to assume there is another way.
Also, guys, I need to use the bathroom.
I don't need to use the bathroom again.
I'll be right back.
I think nobody's going to kill me here.
There is a monster.
Right in front of me, but I don't think he'll notice me.
I should be fine.
He's like right there.
Oh my god, he's moving.
Okay, I think I'll be safe right here.
I'll be Rebecca's.
I'm back.
All right, let's keep going.
All right, let's get my ass kicked.
Is that my ex over there?
I don't know.
I think that's her.
Okay
Here we
go No, my ex!
Ah!
You're a rather skillful.
Wait!
My ex has passing!
Oh my god, it resets everything!
Wait, that's actually worse.
That's actually so much worse.
Oh, my progress.
Oh no.
Don't give them an opening.
Don't worry, I'm trying.
Okay.
Oh, I missed it.
Oh my god, he's...
She's trying to get me closer to the poison swabs!
Oh, this is so...
Oh, there you go.
You don't need that head anyway.
Damn right!
Okay, we're fine.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
Oh, I need to lock in.
No!
I need to lock in!
I'm so scared of actually leaving the arena again.
That was so awkward!
Is that all you've got?
All right, nice.
Another one!
I said to leave.
Don't make me get a restraining order.
Oh, I...
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
It's raising attacks in my...
Oh, fuck, that's it.
I can't...
Oh, shit, that's bad.
Ethan!
Oh, fuck.
I thought you said that.
It's fine.
There's no escape.
Why can't I quit you?
That's struggling got you nowhere.
Oh, my God.
I just can't quit her, guys.
I don't know.
She's just a freak.
She's just... What can I say?
She's...
It's just...
She's just freaking...
Yeah, guys, can you really blame me?
Just knows what to do with that hair.
I'd really like to not be in the poison swaps.
Which keeps me coming back.
Like, where do I go?
Oh, I'm so lost.
I'm just slowly dying.
Oh, this is...
This is bad.
Grab this.
Fuck it.
I'll grab some heals too.
Oh, okay, okay, they're just normals.
Okay, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, fuck!
He let it rip!
You like that?
That's fine.
Okay, all right, buddy.
Okay, chill, chill.
All right.
Is he killing himself?
Was that?
All right, there you go.
No, no, we're finishing it today, guys.
We're gonna finish it today.
Believe.
I'm just a little lost right now.
Where the fuck did he come from?
Just a little lost.
doesn't mean we're not gonna finish
i'm just trying to find the source of the poison the goddamn
poison oh my god this took me nowhere this was just a dead
end where oh okay
Where's the other guy?
Oh, there he is.
Didn't need my sword.
Okay, how do I get up there?
Oh my, this is the entire... Like, how do I get up there?
Oh my god, at least I'll get...
At least there's loot here.
You know, it's the little things.
At least I have loot.
Alright, I got body blocked.
Look out!
Where is it?
Where is he?
Come on, where I... Was that it?
okay look out when you say look out my beautiful wife
usually that means look out behind you not in front of me
like usually that's what look oh oh it was behind me i'm
sorry for ever doubting
you never mind never you're so right you're always right
sweetie it was it was indeed behind me My beautiful wife.
As right as always.
Look, I can't see shit, okay?
Can you really blame me?
I legitimately can't see anything.
Malice no matter where you look.
How far is this spread?
Is there like any way to fucking deal with the malice right
now?
I guess there's a chest here.
Do I get, like, I, oh.
Find his key.
Oh my god, that's fine.
It's just ripping me.
There you go.
Alright, we're sure for time.
Yeah, yeah, maybe if you didn't start it, you would live.
You could have lived a happy life if you stayed there.
If you stayed in the ground, stupid.
That's on you.
These guys are actually pretty weak, though.
I don't know what their purpose is.
Honestly, I feel like they let Miyazaki, like, guest star in
the...
I guest designed this area.
This air fucking...
I hate this air.
I think this is my least favorite path.
Least favorite level so far.
100%.
all right there we go oh this is why yeah no this is my
least fit the worst part is just the fact that i don't know
where how to get to the trees i don't even know if i can get
to the trees
like i don't even know which way i've been to
wait no this is new okay all right nice there's some chests
here some loot loot loot oh i hear the armless noises of
monsters near me they are prepared to fight oh my god
all right oh my god oh it's fine all right they for the loot
buddy die for nothing all
right at least i can enhance now okay we got more oni power
more sword it's always a good thing wait i can we actually
can enhance these things sorry is there anything good that i
need okay duration blazing state that's always good
Oh, you have these I want.
I never use any of these.
I'm not gonna lie.
I mean, fine, whatever.
I don't use any of this anyway.
Oh my god, six?
That's so many.
I'll take that.
I'll take that, yeah.
Because here...
I mean, do I just...
What's...
What?
Head for the center of the key sanctuary.
Like, here?
Oh.
Alright.
Wait, but what's over there?
Wait, but what's over in that tunnel, though?
I'm gonna go into that tunnel first.
That tunnel looks interesting.
Like, I can't because of the poison.
Seems like an interesting tunnel.
Oh, it's just treasure.
There's a monster guarding it in there.
No?
Secret.
Oh!
New item.
Shrack's purple souls.
Uh, Blast.
Making it even more deadly.
Press B to blast enemies and Shrack.
Purposefuls.
Parry and attack to fill.
Golden wave cage.
Boosting wave range.
I guess it's like a farm or what?
I'll vote you with this.
Is it that useful?
Is it actually?
What would be like...
What would be like the strat to use it, guys?
Yeah, I feel...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Whatever.
No, every time.
Every fucking...
Oh, no, he's fucking blue now.
Oh, no.
He's fucking blue, guys.
Oh, no, my other ex!
Wait, let me kill him first.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, it's him.
Oh, my God!
And he's blue now!
The other axe is here.
Oh, God.
They got it.
Okay,
that was scary.
Not gonna laugh.
Oh, she's not even close.
Not even close.
Oh.
Something.
never change oh we're alive we're alive oh I die oh my I
can't help it guys I truly just can't help it yeah when
these are feel released a truly catastrophic golden I don't
know I feel like I won't really use it I have like my main
weapon which is the earth shatter and my birds because the
birds are really good like crowd control in general because
they're like fire I don't know I like the crowd control of
it that it gives me all right we got one of the Fucking
trees.
I...
Oh, oh.
Wrong two buttons, wrong two buttons.
Well done.
Whoops.
That's awkward.
It's okay, I can refill.
All right, nice.
I'll just kill him real quick.
All right.
It's okay.
It's fine.
One tree down.
Okay.
That's a loop.
Okay, we got one of the trees down.
Thank fucking God.
And then...
Yeah.
Well, I wasn't planning on doing Earthshot.
That was just a little misinput on...
Oh, this is a fight.
This is a fight, isn't it?
This is a fight.
I mean, there's poison right now so I can just do this.
Oh wait, these guys are...
Oh my god, I wasted that on these guys.
These guys are so weak.
I didn't have to use the tree.
Oh god, not...
Oh, oh, tree, tree, tree, tree, tree, tree, tree, tree,
tree.
Now you see, this is where I use the tree.
More power to flow from the wreck.
See it.
This is the this is oh my god, he took advantage.
He took advantage of me Oh,
no, oh, no, no, no, not again not again.
Oh, God, please
Oh, please Oh, God, please
No, no, no, no No.
No.
Oh, my God.
He actually fucked me over.
At least I have another tree.
At least I reset my trees.
I couldn't.
I was spamming it, guys.
I swear to God, I was spamming it.
It just wasn't.
It's because there's a delay when it comes to the use.
delay at least i get my other tree tree what the fuck
he said press circle i press circle i swear to god i swear
to god press circle
tree i can't see tree
Tree!
Tree down, tree down.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's scared.
He's scared.
He's actually scared of me.
Oh my god.
I never thought I'd see that possible.
He was actually scared of me.
Well thought.
Alright, let's see.
Alright, let's get this tree up.
Alright, goodbye tree.
Thank God for the fucking tree, guys.
Actually saved by the tree.
That's where I'm supposed to go.
Yeah, I'm supposed to go here.
I told, I knew there were like, I knew that there was like a
way.
Alright, at least they're like, guarded by the weaker guys.
What the fuck?
Why are you so far up from your team, bro?
What are your teams down here?
Well, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I had a garden here, but someone tore up all the trees.
Do you have any idea what, oh, there was termites in your
tree.
They were dead, they were dead dead.
We had to clear it for the safety of the rest of the art
garden.
See, the architecture.
You know, for the safety of your house, you know.
You don't want termites in your house.
Alright, now we can get this shortcut out of here.
Nice.
Okay, which way do I go?
Oh, this way.
Where is this shrine?
I shall grab the shrine and then go back.
Oh.
It looked very shrine-like, though.
You really blame me?
It looked very shrine-like.
Alright.
Oh, there's the last tree.
How the fuck?
Oh, there it is.
Eh.
There you go.
Surprise.
Happy birthday.
Look at that.
What a great birthday present.
Alright.
Oh, finally we got rid of all of that poison swap.
Thank God.
And I'll never come back to this.
The worst part is that, like, I'll never come back to the
area.
That's the worst part for me.
back to it.
There was no point.
Oh, nobody's guiding this one this time.
How many items do I have anyway?
I haven't.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
I have like lots of free money too.
That haven't like cracked open.
What was it called?
There was like gems that can crack open.
Oh, here you go.
Yeah, I forgot about those.
Oh,
it's fine.
I'll use it on the last boss.
You know what?
Just for fun.
You know, fuck it.
You know, just for fun, guys.
Let's see.
Why do I do it?
Storehouse.
Holy shit.
I have so many.
What the fuck?
uh increases health and stamina damage dealt to enemies for
a short duration greatly reduces for a short duration
reduces health and stamina from enemy attacks i mean let me
i might as well get rid of this
like what can i okay gradually restores for a launch okay we
got that oh
uh wait i should have that what the oh yeah we don't need
this oh
yeah we don't need this gradually fills the awakening gauge
for imbues with huge amounts of oh wait excuse me imbued
with huge okay temper exceeds the window to form certain
actions revives you once if you die okay we don't care about
that though fine i don't really care too much about that
wait i can crack this open right
wait can i just oh well then
huh all right let's go i feel like let's let's upgrade our
stuff real quick let's
all right all right let's let's upgrade our stuff real quick
let's buy some upgrades since we're nearing now okay let's
get leather okay leather tempered iron and let's get leather
and temper i real quick i anticipated your visit musashi oh
leather as you wish tempered iron a wise choice the city is
in your hand yeah i i sort of low-key wasted i didn't
realize that that also gave me hp i was just thinking like
other stuff i don't know what i was thinking guys i i
normally i think is normally i don't i'm malice and uh don't
have to send horn okay wait do i need how many do i need two
and two two two two two two two have you need of my aid oh
does it give that yeah they do decided malice site and you
have decided to as you wait until we next meet all right
that's another upgrade and then we'll grab two leather all
right um and two leather Wait, can I get full sword now?
Can I ash?
No.
I'll get up two leather.
I make a technically farm for more.
I don't really want to farm.
I honestly, I think we're fine.
I think we're fine, guys.
Oh, never mind.
I'll just buy one letter for fun.
Just for fun.
Now I'm poor.
Let's go back to the storehouse.
I don't know if I should...
I feel like I should get DPS stuff.
Not gonna lie.
It would make more sense.
Like, maybe this.
I feel like that would be good.
I just pop it all.
Fuck it.
Like, I just pop everything.
Let the world take me.
See where it takes me.
if i had to pop one which one would i pop first pop pop
wait it's only short duration is there a long duration of
that i'm gonna check
oh yeah it's just all short duration i thought it'd be
longer i guess this is the long duration because it's like
gradually restores wait we should put that then.
This is the long-duration one.
Now, there isn't.
This is all short-duration.
Alright, this is the better?
Increases health and sand down.
Greatly increases.
Okay, this is greatly.
We need the greatly increased one.
Alright.
We just pop everything the moment that we get in the boss
fight.
Just let me guide me.
I feel like there's a pig in here.
Oh, there isn't.
Surprise.
Oh my god, not you.
Not you.
Oh god.
Wait, I might have to...
I might have to use bird.
I legitimately don't want to deal with them.
I do not care about these guys.
Okay.
Oh my god, oh my god, wait, that's new.
Holy shit, I never seen that before.
Okay, that's five.
Oh, it's no longer five.
Okay, that's fine.
There we go.
Oh, I hate these guys so much.
They're so annoying.
What the fuck?
The fight ended.
Bro?
What you doing up there?
Everyone was done fighting.
Okay, oh, there's chests up here.
Alright, chest time.
Alright.
Let's see.
We'll go this way.
He didn't hear no bell.
He didn't hear no bell because he wasn't part of the fucking
fight, guys.
He was in a different state.
He got the directions wrong.
He went to San Jose and says San Francisco.
Alright.
I go up here.
Oh, that's not a good sound.
Oh, no.
I'm fine.
I have to fight bosses wildcat.
Oh, wildcat.
Oh,
no.
How do you do that?
out charge without frames they have no advantage where are
you serious i think she is well done unfortunately my
girlfriend is serious am i supposed to go
not going for it i'm okay Don't she said the weird, but I
didn't take her seriously.
Uh, women.
My bad.
Alright, get out of here.
I'm actually done with you.
Oh my god, what?
Where?
I like...
Oh my god, they're over here.
I'll get it.
All right, there we go.
Oh, we're good.
We're good.
It's fine.
We're so healthy, guys.
This is stopping.
All right.
It's okay.
Now I learned.
I'm not really...
Oh, fuck!
I will always listen to you, my beautiful web.
What did I do?
My beautiful wife is always right.
It's just me.
I'm stupid.
I'm a stupid silly.
Oh, shit.
Think you can keep me out, huh?
Good luck.
Just a stupid silly child.
Please don't leave me.
Masashi, there are explosives on top of the gate.
Don't leave me.
I can never do better.
Wait, there's explosives?
Okay, it's explosives in the room with us.
Like...
Oh!
Okay, on my side, blind.
I'm 100% blind.
This game?
That?
No, that's not.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
I can't see through that.
Like, I thought about it.
I was like, am I supposed to shoot that?
Like, I think I did.
I legitimately don't even know what I did.
But I think that's actually what I did.
All right.
Well, now that I know.
uh red no it should be get on with the times it's all about
the blue paint now red paint is like so 1995
uh everyone uses blue and yellow paint now guys
it's so denying me Oh
My it That should destroy it at least I didn't wasn't a boss
but Oh, it's red like yeah paint is the thing of the past
old man now.
It's light
People don't use paint anymore toky but a nice find they use
the power of light all
right here we go that was messy why would the chema bring
such weapons to bear here Arashiyama is a veritable sea of
malice at this point all right these guys are gonna need his
help okay you're not supposed to block after I stay that oh
my god oh my god you okay that's it that's it that's it
that's it that's it i didn't care at first but that's it all
right that's on you buddy this could have been a fair 1v1
yeah that's it
That's what you get.
Look, I was gonna get to you later, all right?
And you were so, they were just so impatient.
There's, like, stuff down here.
Should I fight these guys first?
Oh, that's a little embarrassing.
Like, what is over there?
Oh my god, don't make me come over here.
Don't make me come over.
Don't make...
Oh, I know you're...
Oh, just because you have tree doesn't mean I won't snipe
you.
Alright.
Grab this too.
Alright, now we can go back up.
Alright.
Up time.
Climb, climb.
Oh, the fact that we still have one more area.
Okay.
All right.
Where?
Aw, I'm gonna suck it just because.
I don't know, they just don't deserve to...
They honestly don't deserve to like...
Oh, I'm just gonna...
They don't deserve me using any of my special powers.
Like, I feel like I...
like really bad you know if there's like a lot of people
then yeah but like these guys are just regular joe's are you
even trying to see
like come on waste of my time and resources why the would i
use my fucking power ups on you
All right, off we go.
Oh, oh, lore time.
Lore time.
Lore, lore, lore.
Time to touch you.
Oh, it's getting high.
Finally.
Oh, I am glad for it.
Hashiyama is a place of profound meaning to me.
Let us rest here a while.
That would be nice, but we have company.
Oh, how I've missed this scent.
You, Ganma Skunk, how dare you set foot in our sanctuary!
Whoa.
Whoa, this is our private time.
Oh my god, it got cucked.
What the hell are you supposed to be?
She does not want to throw a balloon.
And I've come to make you a proposition.
I hear you have a taste for human souls.
Thank you.
Interested?
And what's in it for you?
The leftovers.
I happen to be propagating some flowers.
bloom without human corpses.
You don't look like the gardening type.
They're a breed I created.
Should they bloom with the full moon?
They'll release copious malice.
Oh, shit.
The thing is, I know I have at least three more bosses
because I have him, her, and the old man.
That's the worst part.
We refuse to let the gunma lay there.
And he's like, shh, the man's talking.
Gio.
Whoa.
That's fucked up, bro.
Let your wife be.
This is a 50-50 relationship.
I don't know.
Did you just hear what he just said?
He was like, shush, women, let the man up.
Whoa.
Gio.
I can't believe.
Damn.
Did you guys hear?
What you just said?
They can die together.
And so fuck, did he just man slain?
Never mind not couple goals.
See, me and my woman, I let her speak her mind.
She might not always be.
Joke up, joke, joke, joke.
But I let her speak.
okay misogyny in the feudal period say it ain't so
not my feudal japan
i honestly cannot relate to this game i
Historically accurate.
Alright, here we go.
We're just gonna throw this.
Fire!
Oh my god.
I didn't realize.
That's crazy.
I thought he lives through that.
There we go.
What?
Alright.
really is that all you've got all right that's easy it's
crazy that he lived that though it's not expect what i gotta
prove irisium irisium or whatever all right yeah bro tank
the fucking bomb
wait which way is the right way oh no i'm not lost oh this
way The answer is, Dorky's always last.
She is always last.
Wait, what?
Something glowed.
Where did it glow on?
Oh, it's the fucking threads.
God damn, it's always the threads.
At least I can level my armor.
Oh, there's a lot of them, too.
Oh no.
Oh geez.
Okay.
Oh, I don't like this.
This is very heavy poison too.
Oh, the poison is so heavy.
I do not like that.
Oh, I am not a fan of this area at all.
No, no, bitch!
Okay, now these guys are annoying.
Now these guys are actually annoying.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, I can't see!
Alright.
Alright, now I don't like them.
Yeah, I just have to...
these guys out of here all right there you go oh my god get
me out of the city get me out of here i hate this area sucks
okay one poison tree down at least
okay we got that poisoning tree gone at least i'll take it
what the Oh, this just is...
How do I get to...
That area?
Oh, I don't need that.
Aww, that wastes it for me.
Okay, at least that's loot.
I'm just glad I got rid of one poison area, but there's
like... how do I get over there?
There's like clearly a...
Like, how?
Oh, this one's a little confusing.
I don't know how to get to that house area.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, not like that.
Are you here?
Have I been here before?
Oh, I think it's here.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, my God.
I guess the X.
Oh.
Oh god.
Oh thank god.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
No shit!
I don't know what it is about him!
You never had a chance to beat him.
Oh god again!
One down.
out it's always my ex it's always him
just something about him
what the fuck oh my god okay
boom all right oh nice actually oh that's so helpful oh fuck
don't make me i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it
bird bird bird oh shit oh come on that's bullshit that's
bullshit I was trying to bird oh wait nothing okay there you
go all right bird out of the way this is the only time I use
bird or use my power-ups They're just way too annoying for
me.
Oh, I don't like this area.
There's so many fire stuff.
What the fuck?
Oh, why is it outside?
They are prepared to fight.
Where?
Oh, there!
Damn it!
I hate you so much.
Oh my god, I hate you.
Oh, only I will burn if I have to.
I will burn if I have...
Oh, I don't have to burn.
I will only...
I imagine he's only just for him.
That's how much I fucking hate these enemies.
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
I will burn if I have to.
Don't...
Don't threaten me.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
That was where the tree was the entire time.
Well, that could have saved me a lot of trouble.
Oh, that's just the worst part.
I know there's at least three more bosses.
Like, I know.
The fact that I know there's so many more bosses left to go.
Does it need loot?
I need important loot.
Wait.
Why would there be like...
On the...
Oh, whatever.
I don't care enough.
Is this way.
Because there's still the fucking main bosses that haven't
killed yet.
So look at what I'm thinking about.
I still have the three main bosses.
So it's like...
Unless the main boss is next one.
Like the plot bosses.
Can't be more, like, filler bosses, less.
Alright.
Okay, guys.
I did fight a lot of the mini-bosses, though, I will say.
Alright, there's been a lot of mini-bosses that I fought.
Oh, shit.
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
it right behind me.
Oh, fuck.
Not more pies and swabs.
Of course they made the last area just all poison.
The fact that it's the last area, like the second last area.
Damn monsters.
is this how it ends I'm like right here bro oh do I'm not
not do I'm not maddy I'll deal with these things you just
stay there and don't worry that oh my god dodge oh what the
fuck don't dodge I'm fucking trying to kill you
Oh, yeah.
How are you so strong?
Don't get too excited.
I'm dual wielding.
I'm not doing this alone.
Oh, there's more.
I fucking knew there's more.
There is always more.
Oh, fuck.
Let it rip.
Oh, my God.
I forgot.
I haven't fights these guys too often.
Oh, don't make me fucking shoot an arrow in your head.
Is he dead?
Yeah, he's dead.
Or is that it?
On your guard.
Oh.
Okay.
You keep coming.
Gotta work on your aim, bro.
I sense yet more enemies.
Remain vigilant.
I'm not going to use the fire yet because they're all just
like baby enemies.
So, okay, I'm using fire.
I'm using tree.
I'm...
Yeah, no, no, no, I...
These...
Yeah, no, you...
No, you get the tree.
You 100%.
I'm going to...
I'm going to the...
I'm fucking throwing a fire.
Fucking...
I don't care.
God, I love you.
That's clear.
These are my exceptions.
No, fuck these guys.
Like, these guys are just...
Nearly one shot.
Yeah.
Oh, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Nope.
Are you...
Okay, I got him.
I will use all of this just to...
Just to kill you guys.
I will use them.
Is that the loss of them?
I believe so.
There you go.
You handle that well.
Chuck's explosives at them.
Thank you I'm searching for another bomb tab spews out this
disgusting fog I saw something like that along with some
monsters on Kamiyama I thought to fight them, but What
nothing to be ashamed of those are not your regular bad guys
Leave them to me Yeah, they're pretty yeah, they look like
they sort of look like demons Here.
Take the key to the gate.
Is there something?
Alright.
Nice.
I got a key.
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's fine.
Fuck that one rock in particular.
Try to find the tree.
I unlocked this.
Oh, I guess I was supposed to like fight around the arena
I'm well like there was no point honestly There was no point
of fight around like I got everything I needed in that one
They're like one shot I guess it's I guess the assumption is
that I wouldn't be abusing my bow I stood my ground yeah I
think it's also the assumption that they assume that players
won't be fucking playing a shooter game in a in a samurai in
a samurai game
let this be the last if you were to consume any more i plan
to think what would become oh shit he's going through he's
relapsing right now just a little more oh and then i'll be
able to beat
a bloody mess of me in the hell oh that's what it's called
right when someone hasn't taken the dirt got their fix in a
while they like he's going cold turkey he just needs one
more fix just one more yeah he's having a bad trip right now
just one more i swear this is the last hit and then i'm
gonna
He's going through, yeah, he's going through a trials right
now.
As long as you live and breathe, that's enough for me.
One more hit, I'll go straight after you, I swear.
Enough for me.
Bro, his girl's like, I can fix him.
Oh,
fuck.
Oh, shit.
I'll tear him, limb from limb.
The more she can fix him.
I got my souls.
You can feed the bodies to flowers or eat them yourself if I
don't give a damn.
Oh, I don't eat humans.
I'm not like the Genma.
My dear.
Then... why do you follow Yoshitsune?
It's going through his jaws right now.
How about we save that as a fun surprise for later?
He wants to defeat Yoshitsune.
Our goals are aligned, but...
But our methods aren't.
If we cross paths, it can only end in a fight.
Oh man, there's...
you might be you may or may not have a problem guys there's
a think he's an addict he's a soul addict oh my god not a
dog come on bro what i can't do anything about where
where am i going from
oh my god it's all over there Oh my god, there we go.
Ah, shit!
Caddans got me.
I'm looking up, but like, where are they positioned?
Oh, there he is.
Oh god, get out of here.
Like, aww.
They're in the walls!
Oh wait, loot.
Loot, loot, loot.
Well, all right, let's go up.
I think they're up here.
They have to be up here.
I'm coming to get you.
Oh, you think you can run away?
Oh, you thought you could...
Oh, you thought you got the high ground?
That's fucking red.
Let's get both.
Oh, my God.
Not you.
No, I'm...
No.
I don't care.
I... I do not know.
Like anything if it means, like, I don't have to deal with
you.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god.
God fucking course, they'll spam this shit.
Wait, what?
Oh, there it is.
That's what I needed.
Aim what?
Aim what, huh?
That's right, I'm coming to get you.
I'm right here, I'm right behind you.
Wait, what?
Oh.
No, this is the right way.
Okay, this is the right way.
Alright, where are our trees?
Oh, I couldn't headshot.
They're so high up.
There we go.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, wait, he's still there!
Okay, there's no way.
Oh, I'm...
Whoops.
Okay, I didn't realize there was more to that than meets the
eyes.
I will kill.
I think it's here.
Okay, yeah, I know he's right here.
Oh, I'm coming over.
That's right.
Little stupid to have explosive news.
to the cannon but who am I to judge demons I knew I knew
there was a way to destroy that's like there's no way
there's no way he just refires me be on your guard yeah what
about what I'm gonna do oh oh I guess that's what he's gonna
do.
I definitely need kills.
No way.
I was gonna say there's no way he gets me here.
Where the fuck is the explosive barrel?
Oh, it's here.
Alright.
Wait, there's stuff here though.
Yeah, what's gonna do is shoot okay he then pursues the
shooter okay but where's where
i don't where
oh there's more to it i thought that was like are you
fucking um oh don't don't don't make me i'm so i'm so
tempted i'm i will use the oni if i have to i
Oh, don't go!
I will click the button.
I will click it.
Oh my god.
I will...
I'll both heal it.
That's really maddening.
God, I hate this area.
The fact that it's called Swamp 2, like...
Swamp 1 and Swamp 2.
Oh my god, this is the word the word.
I I I'm still enjoying the game.
I just hate poison swamps It doesn't matter how good the
game is.
I just I I just hate I hate playing with poison swamp like
poison swamp like areas It's just not fun.
I don't find it a fun experience.
I
I legitimately don't think it's fun.
Alright, I'm losing it.
Oh, actually...
Get ready!
There we go.
Alright, let's get this guy up.
I'm assuming it's fun for the viewer, but I don't know.
I don't think it's a...
I personally don't find the concept of poison.
Does anyone, though?
Does anyone find poison?
Actual poison, but...
Alright.
Oh, these guys were easy.
I didn't have to use fire.
Yeah, but then, like...
Maybe you guys are...
That's a bit of masochist behavior, too.
who enjoy tanking like me there's a correlation between tank
players and poison swap enjoyers
oh hello you got here sooner than I expected the festivities
haven't started yet oh they're waiting for me suffering
builds character you act like you're working for Yoshitsune
oh she's into that
Yes, it's me is a great man and my love for him is sincere.
I've sworn my loyalty to him, you know Working under him is
no act either But achieving his goals is not where your
goals end is it Oh, you were eavesdropping when I spoke to
gamma you Actually, do you really have time to pry into my
affairs?
Oh Wait, but she was gonna give us more info.
She was...
Oh, there it is.
Oh, there's the flower malice.
The flower has hair.
Fine.
As soon as you've dealt with the source of the malice at the
top, we'll take care of Gunnyu.
I think for me, it's just the fact that it's the second last
area, too.
I know, that's why.
Like, if it was in the beginning, then fine.
But then I'm like, oh, I'm about to finish the game.
And then you're like, and I'm like, well, but it's all
poison.
It's just surprise.
Oh, this guy's a chubby little guy.
Oh, holy shit.
Oh, no, it's my axe.
Oh, my.
Oh, God.
I'm going to kill him first.
No, don't!
Okay.
There we go.
Oh god, a fucking course.
A quick course.
A fucking course.
I hate you so much.
I hate you so much!
Yeah.
Alright.
He gets me every time.
every fucking time
always the broadsword users at least just because they're so
delayed with their attacks so it fucks with me alright lore
time oh we're dropping it like it's hot with all these lore
these lore dumping on me
dookyo and and yostune when he was still an ony mission oh
my both the ony and the humans turn their swords on you
unfortunately so it would seem oh don't be so dramatic this
is why you had me create this new ony gauntlet is it not oh
wait what wait she created it now try it on
Hmm?
What's here?
Oh?
I feel a prying gaze from some few hundred years away.
What is the meaning of this?
Our gauntlets should be beyond your power to create.
I can't quite make out your yammering.
But...
It's about the gauntlet, I presume.
I speak only truths.
The gauntlets, even the spirit mirrors.
My people taught the Oni how to make oh what she made me
okay she made it all i see red oh whoa oh whoa
crimson yeah they see him in the past yeah after i die i'll
take the only power you've given me and stain head oh she
likes a bad boy and then i'll come back here and bathe this
entire world in red as well freaking freaky crimson sanguine
scarlet vermillion red oh my god he likes an audience too he
did not care when it was just her too
oh my god this plot twist she was like oh she created the
entire time over here no she's probably working ever so hard
doesn't she know it's all in vain so they knew already they
knew about them since the beginning red oh so it's like a
was it's like a prophecy like uh what's the word where where
it's bloody rage everything goes exactly as our planet
everything there are no exceptions
that actually got me that actually got me it's like
self-fulfilled prophecy yeah it's a self-fulfilled prophecy
so like he knew he visited in the past to stop it but then
they knew already and then they were the ones that chose him
because they knew that he was the guy that visited him in
the past and it's just self-fulfilling it's a cycle when it
comes to those two it's because of this visit that caused
the whole thing but without the visit they wouldn't he
wouldn't be here even get rid of the source of the malice
your sin is making us look like idiots oh my god my back in
this swamp oh my god i'm back they took me back there's a
time loop right they heard how much i love this malice too
either way it'll mess with whatever dojo's up to let's go
yeah that's not fair those two are on new game plus all
roads lead to the swamp oh no no
there's arrow guy they should prove no much for you I think
my bow is a little stronger just so...
What the fuck?
What is water gonna do to me?
Like...
Alright.
Where's the other one?
Get rid of her.
Wait.
Where's the other one?
Come on.
Oh, there you are.
I like how the arrows stuck there.
Well done.
I think you could have won that twice.
Or at least it's not swamp.
It's just water.
I'm fine with that.
I'm fine with water.
Oh my god.
Am I close enough?
I am not close enough.
I suck.
Here we go.
Look at that one guy in particular too.
Wait.
Oh, he survived.
All right, nice.
Am I not?
Oh, I'm gonna just shoot him from here.
I love my Onimusha way of the bow game.
This is the longest of us not having a single boss fight so
far.
It's going to be the next one, isn't it?
Aw, shit, it's gonna be...
I'm heading there right now, aren't I?
I...
Oh, shit, it's Roger, isn't it?
Alright, at least we got more loot.
I mean, technically this game has been 90%, Bo.
The 10% is why I fight the bosses.
Because I cat-headshot them.
Okay, that's just, I was...
I was pre-getting ready to pre-five.
They are prepared to fight.
Oh my god, don't make me do it.
I will do it.
I, you know what?
Uh...
Nope.
I will, don't make me do it.
Don't... Don't make me do it.
Don't make me do it.
Don't...
Oh, you're so, you know, I thought about it.
Oh, I, okay, that was actually sick.
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, it's 100%.
Yep.
Pure aura.
I thought about it.
I did think about it.
I'm gonna fire just in case.
What is that?
Like, is he trying to block my way?
On your guard.
Where?
Oh.
That's fine.
That did so much damage.
What the fuck?
Where do I go, though?
Oh my god, I didn't see him.
Alright, there you go.
I didn't need my sword.
She's sucking up.
Oh, she's sucking up the sores.
Bro, close your mouth.
It's rude.
Alright.
Here it comes.
Yeah, fire hit fucking hard.
I'm trying to figure out which way I'm supposed to go?
Jesus Christ, what is this?
Okay, this way is extra loot.
Yeah.
But why the rocks?
I don't understand the rocks part.
Like, yeah, I know there's no pathway here.
Oh my god, this area is fucking huge.
It is long.
I don't know if they're like...
I don't know.
I will say, like I said, I'm not a huge fan of this level so
far.
Victory is ours.
Lots of padding.
The last era feels a lot of padding.
Because I haven't been fighting any bosses, too.
So it's mostly been, like, small minions.
To battle.
Alright.
Look out.
What?
Oh, I didn't see you.
Whoa, man.
Get over here.
No, I'll finish this today.
It's just a particularly long area.
Yeah, no mini bosses.
It's just all minions.
So I'm like, I don't know.
I'm not sure yet how I feel.
I'm like, currently I'm not a huge fan of this area.
Impressive bug technique.
Alright, fuck it.
There you go.
Yeah, it feels a little too much padding on it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, game padding type deal.
That's why I'm, like, not a huge fan of this area because of
it.
Oh, no.
Maybe there's something in here.
Like, whoops.
Oh, I hope there's no enemies.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Whoops.
All right, it might be tabbed.
Wait, I can...
Maybe?
Oh, shit.
Okay, I got...
Okay, wait, I gotta get rid of this tree.
Get rid of this tree real quick.
There we go.
Do I have another one?
Yes!
Oh, fuck!
There we go.
Oh, he's blue, too.
Okay.
All right, nice.
Oh, fuck, not nice.
You never had a chance.
That's it.
I don't know.
That's that, then.
Just that easy.
More loot.
Need that.
We know what you want, Doki.
You just want more point.
Yes, yes, that's exactly what this area was missing.
We were just missing more poison!
Enough said, Doki.
Add more poison.
Turning here?
Or is this a shortcut?
Oh, it's loot.
Oh, pathways to loot.
Alright.
Boop.
Oh.
All right.
Let's go this way.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, wait, I need that.
Oh, I thought that was like the material for crafting, but
it's just the power of stem saving for Onimusha 7, I guess.
all right now we go this way
and oh all right is this a boss area no I was gonna say this
is an open area but I don't think it's a boss area god
they're gonna chuck me like the hardest fucking boss ever
and I'm stuck in there for it I can see it already I'm just
stuck in there for an hour am I
Oh, there's the malice flower.
Over this bridge is a scumbag named Sasaki Gunya.
We're going to kill him.
There's nothing poetic about it.
Oh, here it comes.
We're getting there.
We're getting closer.
Oh, yeah, the giant circle.
Hmm.
Well, it's very...
Well, it looks particularly boss-like.
Oh, I wonder where the boss is.
Oh, I'm...
I wonder where I'm gonna get my next boss.
Yeah, the giant boss, my shaved arena, right here.
in here.
Alright, we don't want to eat.
Okay, creases.
Okay, we gotta grab that.
Surely not.
Surely this giant circle is just loot, right?
Okay.
Alright, good.
Lore boss number one.
When I just come to Kyoto.
I'm missing Lore boss.
There's a girl dancing at Oh, is that my girl?
Said it was called a kabuki dance or something.
She was only a kid.
But damn, I was enchanted.
You stay away from her.
Oh?
What?
You know her.
And if I do?
Oh, well.
get that have you gotten any stronger at all oh great
warrior you're not gonna disappoint me like last time are
you that was the first time i ever lost yeah and he was
doping he was doping come on and the lost that wasn't fair
yeah we don't talk about all the rewind time we did there
Kiyo Go big end one me too Good Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I'm going to put you that Yoshitsune Musashi, but
first let's have some Oh, God.
I can't remember.
I don't remember how to fight this person.
I'm taking that stupid head of yours I don't remember right
some more time and help.
Oh my god.
It's the
Oh This is fun Okay, I don't I forgot that I had the wrong
one equipped.
I'm just getting started got you That's awkward for me Oh my
god, press circle.
Oh, I did.
Yeah, that's right.
I did Yeah, I did oh shit it matters not okay
Oh, power grows.
Smash him flat, yo.
Very well.
I shouldn't hold back then.
Oh, nice.
Oh, I got just in time.
What is it?
What the fuck?
No, my extra damage!
Okay, headshot that's...
Oh, okay, never mind.
Oh, right, Scott.
Okay, I don't like that.
He's enjoying that a lot, guys.
I...
It might be a little...
He's a little bit...
Getting freaky right now.
You are so beautiful and wise here.
He's sad.
Okay.
Memories of my life.
All right, there you go.
know there's a phase two i don't i can feel it i can feel it
oh my god this phase two is calling for me right now i'll
lend you my aid and this critic quickly he's calling for me
the phase two dear that musashi it's time to die oh my god
that's bullshit that's bullshit
Okay.
No, no, I didn't miss it!
This is the end of you, cockroach.
All right.
Oh, fuck.
That was close.
Oh, that was not close.
And after you said all those words, too.
There you go.
all right you're not going anywhere don't miss it now okay
here you go die just perish
nice just try and stop this one Okay, that was bullshit.
No, I didn't see the blue!
My power, girl!
You look terrible, Nassashi.
Okay.
That's not fair.
He's trying to stop this one.
Okay.
Do you want some more of that?
Oh, that's not fair.
That is not fair!
Why ever did you think you could win?
Oh!
You're not getting there.
No!
He was like, he did so many combos there.
I couldn't fucking react to it.
Oh, that was so close.
Yeah, that was so close.
We settle this today, Musashi.
I fucking go.
My god, the fact that that wasn't the first one.
That's bullshit.
I'm so mad.
You're the hope for this world.
It's over.
What is said and you're gone.
Allowing you to consume those flowers will put us at a
greater disadvantage.
You must find a way to stop them.
Oh my god, he's fucking me up!
He's fucking me up!
Right here and now.
It's over.
Okay.
Holy shit, he fucked me up there.
He kept...
This is bad.
I lost a lot of advantage.
Okay, I'm locking in.
Hold back then.
Die!
Just perish!
Here we go.
What a lie, idiot!
Alright.
Fucking hell.
This isn't worth our time.
Oh.
Are you kidding me?
Why ever did you think you could win?
All right.
Bro, okay, all right.
Here we go.
Oh.
Beautiful, beautiful, beautiful, beautiful.
Thank you, you know what, be?
You know what, be better?
Sisikou, baby, fight with me!
You know?
You know what, be pretty.
cool you know be very helpful you fight with me it's gonna
take a lot more than that to kill me oh it's beautiful oh
yeah you know could help me too my beautiful life to its
bloody end you want some more of that oh my god isn't it
worth our time
so fucking all right
it's just so okay there you go oh my god you heal what it's
oh he does so much damage he does so much all right all
right all right oh my uh okay okay okay i'm gonna lock in
this today, Musashi.
No, it sounds like they're locked in.
Okay, I was locked in the half.
Good.
Okay, Odi, I need your power.
Now is the time.
Use this then.
How dare you?
Thanks.
Alright.
Listen again?
All right.
Full focus.
I'm trying to full focus now.
I hate it.
I don't want them to watch the tweet.
I'm just...
the watch is 20 more times to its bloody end what's in line
idiot okay guys he's got so much damage too holy shit put
your back into it all right that's good
No challenge at all.
This one done.
Oh, he's so stymied.
Grant the Sashio strength.
Smash him flat, yo!
Very well.
I shouldn't hold back then.
Oh my god.
Here you go.
Oh, come!
Oh, that's okay.
That attack was so delayed That's not fair That attack was
so delayed Dear that Musashi, it's time to die No!
Oh my god
Jesus Christ Are you kidding me?
And after you said over your words I'm mad!
Oh my god.
Oh,
that's so fast.
This is the end of you.
Okay, this is where my fucking head is.
I'm taking that stupid head of y'all.
You need some more time in hell.
Oh my god.
I'm just getting started.
okay
now it's a time use a set try it oh my god you fish all
right it's fine it's fine it's fine these two are much made
in hell he's so annoying it's gonna take a lot more than
that to kill me
He's actually so fucking annoying to fight.
Let's save this fight to its bloody end.
How dare you?
I'm just gonna do that.
I have to.
I don't think I have enough easel for it.
Are you kidding me?
He does so much things.
Oh, I can't.
Cut off what she will.
I think I said not.
Let us teach them the meaning of pain.
What?
That's bullshit!
And after you said all those words too.
Oh my god, this is actually bullshit.
Just perish.
Okay.
Don't miss it now.
Like, please.
You're weak, weak, so damn weak.
you fraud Oh my god I should not even on the first phase I'm
dodging I swear to god Don't okay, no, I pressed circle I
pressed circle
Just try stop
Oh my god, my first trial was my best one.
Focus.
I'm taking that stupid head of yours.
You need some more time in hell.
Swing.
Yeah.
I hate you.
That he can't time it.
Don't miss it now.
Oh my god.
We got this at least.
It's just my kryptonite.
It's always my kryptonite.
Allowing Gil to consume those flowers will put us at a great
disadvantage.
He must find a way to stop her.
These two are a match made in hell.
Which is why it falls to us to stop them from here.
and now there you go
what okay that was a fucking parry right there it matters
not that should have been parry your best how damn all right
oh i have to watch this again i all right time to watch this
again it's gonna take a lot more than that okay
can get uh to its bloody end dude let's get that
grab that so i can have this oh this is fun oh my god i
swear to god i died another road may protect me forever did
you think you could win
doesn't matter Smash him flat, yo!
Very well.
I shan't hold back then.
Watch and learn, idiot.
He's so fucking un- Oh my god, I can't counter it when he
gets the first hit?
On that?
Like, I can't block it.
That's the worst part.
Why can't I block it?
...
If you are once so beautiful, you want to ski up.
Here we go.
It pains me so to see what he's becoming.
Yeah, he lands it.
I can't do anything.
My life I will only have all but faded.
Now I live only to watch over my dear.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Oh, too fast.
You're weak, weak so damn weak, you fraud.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm fucking...
This isn't worth our time.
Oh.
My aid.
End this Cretan quickly and be done with him.
Fine.
Dear that, Musashi, it's time to die.
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
Go
away for you.
All right, that's bullshit.
That's actually bullshit.
Oh my god.
Fuck it.
Miracle, I was literally dead, guys.
Guys, oh my god, are you fucking getting me?
Just try and stop this one.
Here.
You can literally see me dodge it, too.
That's the worst part.
I need more.
Oh, this isn't worth our time.
You must heal quickly.
Are you fucking...
How do you settle those words, too?
I tried heals!
Oh, I don't have heals!
We should have to find some healing.
I didn't even realize I don't have heals anymore.
I really have gotten too strong.
Oh.
Oh my god, I pressed circle.
I'm so tilted.
I actually pressed circle too.
Oh my god, I'm going to use fire again.
Because it's not autoed for me.
Die.
Just perish.
You want some more of that?
Do you have some wagon wolves?
Is that your best?
I'm locking you now.
Allowing Gale to consume those flowers for a good at a great
disadvantage.
She must find a way to stop.
These two are a match made in the home.
Oh my god.
I hate watching this part.
I hate watching this a lot more than that to kill me
To its bloody end
Okay, there you go.
That's like a grab for this guy.
That's good
Cut off what you my god it must He's not.
Bye.
There we go.
You see him right here?
It's over.
Oh.
All right.
Got that.
Oh, I'm so beautiful.
Nope.
Wise girl.
Oh, I wish you would actually help.
My wife.
The memories of our power grows.
I wish my wife would help me.
really do you're mine all right okay very well I shan't hold
back then okay that's cool that's cool why ever did you
think you could win okay
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
All right.
That's fine.
That's scared.
That actually scared me.
I'm just getting started, can't you?
I'll lend you my aid.
End this cretin quickly and be done with him.
Fine.
Dear that, Musashi, it's time to die.
Hmm?
All right.
nicely done I'm so unlike I
I'm all right oh my god you're stupid fucking wife I'm not
jealous I'm just very ah fuck you you're the terrible
Masashi oh oh oh oh You're not going anywhere.
No!
Okay, come on, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal.
Alright.
Swing!
Okay.
Oh.
I swear to God, guys, I am trying so hard to heal.
Okay.
Are you kidding me?
No scurrying away for you.
But bright.
Oh my god.
Fucking Quartz.
That hits me.
There'll be nothing left of you and I'm done.
Okay.
That's close.
No, no!
You're not going anywhere!
You are so...
Oh my god!
Time to finish you off!
I pressed circle.
I spammed it too.
I saw it and I spammed it.
The fact I spammed it.
the button too and it didn't work this is kill or die crying
we both know how this works gun you
yeah all right come on i 100 i can deflect that is that your
best how dare you all right
Cut off watching you.
All right, you sit again?
It's not.
All right.
I'm fucking, I'm, I need, I need less cutscene.
I'm tired of, I'm tired of watching that cutscene.
I'm sorry, I'm so tired of watching that cutscene.
I don't care.
I'm so tired of watching it.
This ends now.
perish what why did it what happened to my oh my god okay
whatever what happened to my move hold back
all right saw it coming Oh, it didn't.
Yeah, I tried.
I held it.
So I'm so confused.
Oh, this is fun.
All right.
Are you kidding me?
There was a silly one.
What?
Okay, whatever.
Okay.
Fuck me, I guess.
Okay,
I know I use X there.
Put your back into it.
Alright.
You're weak.
Oh.
I need a heal, though.
We can quickly and be done with him.
Fine.
I wish I could see.
Get this.
It's time to die.
I fucking deflected you whore!
Okay.
It's fine.
It doesn't matter.
I don't know why.
I pressed circle, but it doesn't dodge anymore.
Yeah.
Take this.
I'm actually tilted take his head go I'm actually okay I'm
gonna go full non-verbal I'm actually till I'm so I'm so
tilted right now I'm I'm so tilted the thing is I'm I'm able
to dodge every I've done it for every other boss some more
time in hell die just perish how dare you like you're just
something about it i'm just getting started god here or do i
need your powers now it's the time give us a sense oh i'm
cutting i'm cutting her out i don't i don't want to watch
that like i've seen i'm so done all right no i'm horrible
What you will, it matters not!
You are once so beautiful and wise, Gion.
It pains me so to see what you've become.
Memories of my life as an honor have all but faded.
Now I live only to watch over my dear, sweet Gion.
You're defenseless.
I need more.
You can't stop it.
Okay.
Smash him flat, Gio!
Very well.
I shan't hold back then.
Die and rot
it.
Oh, this is fun.
Yes!
Cut that out!
Yeah.
I'll lend you my aid.
End this crit.
Err.
At least I got that.
Fine.
Hear that, Bukashi.
It's time to die.
Don't miss it now.
Please don't tell me he's going, oh, I'm gonna have to watch
this stupid cutscene.
I have to watch this.
He's gonna take a lot more than that to kill me.
Oh my god.
Come here.
Let's save him.
Stupid fucking cutscene.
It's fine.
Brace yourself.
It's over.
Die and rot in your own field.
Take this.
Are you kidding me?
Why ever?
I fucking pressed deflates.
I pressed deflates.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just try and stop this one.
I'm just getting started, Ganyu.
Oh, this is fun.
There'll be nothing left of you, and I'm done.
Ah.
Okay.
This is the end of you, Cockroach!
Take this!
Time to finish you off!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Die!
And rot in your own field!
You're not going anywhere!
There'll be nothing left of you and I'm done!
Are you kidding me?!
Just try and stop this one!
Oh my god!
I'm so mad!
No scurrying away for you!
Oh, wait!
This is it!
is that oh my god oh
my god where's my way please
i'm just so happy as well are we done here i think welcome
to tomato farm welcome welcome this richard thing thank you
god he's doing so happy holy there's just something about it
oh god he'll be fine oh wait that says only goblin oh wait
he's just gonna oh wait yeah he's just gonna rip apart
because he's just he's connected with the only goblin just a
pile of human flesh now
I need my gold legs.
They're sneakies.
Oh my god.
Stupid bastard.
Oh shit bro, the body's not even cold yet.
Oh, it's so...
I'm just happy I'm fucking finished with this guy.
I'm so fucking happy.
Bro, fuck this guy.
Like...
Oh my god.
i don't know just fighting him was just i don't know man
fighting him man just fighting him it's just not it for me
i'm just glad it's a he just broke him in a stupid metal hat
bro bro bro just needed to check in the rehab bro top arena
number two coming right oh toky you did you enjoy that are
you ready for arena number too snowy thank you again for the
50 gifted ships snowy thank you we did it guys we separated
we broke a toxic relationship she was he was not good for
her guys he she used to be a straight a student and then she
metamorphosized she was not they were not good for each
other guys she used to be a straight a student
We did it.
We broke them apart.
We broke a toxic relationship.
Oh my, I'm just glad it's over.
I'm just so happy.
Bro was carried to your elo with his due.
Yeah.
Bro, bro, she...
He had a pocket mercy.
That's not fair.
like
wasn't fair bro had a pocket mercy in this wasn't bro got
healed every time I got him low
come on bro right I'm just glad it had silver that's it
there were no much for you at all I'm so glad that was
fucking over bro I'm so over I'm actually so over it guys
i'm i'm bro i don't even had a senata bro i fucking didn't
my team didn't even pick a support what do you mean my team
didn't even have a support
oh my god they were just too toxic for each other guys
i was like to my wife you should have picked mercy He was
like, I'm running Mercy.
I'm running Tracer.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, how many times I can do that?
Bro?
Oh my god, apparently I'm not enough.
Should have been Mercy.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
see no you don't oh god oh i can dodge that though oh wow
but dodging that is fucking fine but dodging that was easy
yeah i was discord screen sharing to my e-kidden it's not
fair my kitten's bronze and all i get i was discord screen
sharing for it
all right let's see
all right here we go arena number wait there's a chest here
i'm not rematch guys i'm not fucking i'm not rematching guys
you cannot make me rematch this fucker i'm so over it
oh take that oh here we go just got off just got out of a
boss fight ready for another one i guess
all right can i enhance anything how much money do i have
how do i know oh i can all right it's checking by some
upgrades oh here we go again all right how What do I need
for upgrades?
Okay, the closest is leather.
I'll just buy leather.
If I can buy temper iron and temper island, that will help
too.
I'll go with leather first.
Have you need of my aid?
This one, correct?
A wise choice.
Okay, and then...
Do I have enough?
I do.
A wise choice.
You have decided?
Very well.
Farewell, my friends.
oh yeah i maxed out every maxed out the ones i need
okay do i have enough for another iron no i could get i
could get more armor though i have enough for two leather
for sure have you need of my aid hmm yeah a wise city is in
your hands yeah the upgrades are so expensive now.
At least I can upgrade armor.
Okay, here we go.
Fast fight number two.
I wonder what happened.
I haven't.
Oh dear.
You just keep killing things.
I thought you couldn't.
I killed your flowers too.
Shame about whatever it was you had planned.
Has
remained unharmed?
Your bluffs are not convincing anyone.
Really, Shizuka.
A ghost lady and a gauntlet lecturing me about blushing.
Learn your place.
I never know where this place is, girl.
And I think you'll be so rude when I put all that effort
into stitching together what you Shizune tore up well it's
not like i did it for your benefit anyway why is my wife
there
i'm out oh it was wonders for my mood you know see as long
as i put it back together i can tear you apart as many times
as i was with my wife's best body doing here did you know
your corpses stay warm when you're dead on it the soul has
departed and yet the flesh the organs they remain fresh okay
but like who is feeding that body what a waste in the
bathroom situation oh my god okay that body should not
survive the impact it's supper time leave not a single No!
Shizuka!
He wasn't an empty vessel.
If no father used to me.
Oh, she did destroy it.
You can't tell me you're alright with this.
Oh, fuck!
I've never been less alright.
Would you mind if I could?
If I had the strength.
I would beat her to bloody pulp with my bare hands.
Don't kill her.
Where's she actually in the fight for Wolverine now?
Oh my, did that upset you?
I suppose it would.
Oh, I'm so glad to hear it.
You lack that strength because you gave it to me.
it's not the same but i'll tear her apart for you she was
angry angry please oh i guess she's gonna be a ghost forever
forever the bottom of hell is create a new body for it right
that's where you're going
oh god okay all right go there we go oh my god stop running
damn it what am i oh my god am i tohoing am i tohoing oh my
god i'm toho oh my god it's toho it's toho stay still how
about a little game You need to shoot the fake.
Use the power of the Oni.
I'm fucking...
Fly!
Have at him.
Which route is the best part of Valer here?
Oh my god.
I think I hate this.
I guess I think I hate this.
You're going to pay for everything.
what you did to shizuka there's no place in this world
besides my god i hate this sword with such pointed words oh
my god these suitors lining up treasure and order for my
hand in the hell
i'm done with this boss
Oh my god, I...
Oops.
This is it.
Here it comes.
Your desperation is oh so laughable.
You really try to piss me off.
Oh my god, get over here.
You can run, but...
No!
So mad.
I'm sad.
uh-oh meet your executioners
that luck won't last
i know it you
really try to piss me off i don't why am i am so angry oh
I'm so angry well I'm so angry and end him when you come
crashing down what oh okay at least now I know
Twist and turn.
I won't entertain money.
Here it comes.
Oh my god!
I fucking buried it!
I swear to god!
How about this?
Oh my god.
Here you are!
Then tell me that you can beat me.
Who do you think it is you're fighting?
Uh-oh.
Burn down to the mellow.
Oh my god, I was trying to get what that was like.
Boom.
How about this?
Catch me if you can.
You really try to piss me off.
Twist and turn.
It's okay I'm there I'm there I'm there I made it I made it
I made it I fucking made it all she has You have the worst
part I'm
God grant possession your strength It's over What is said
that you're not So
How about a little game?
Oh my god, I couldn't fucking do my thing to it.
This is beneath me.
Oh, what is this?
What is this?
You must find cover quickly.
I must find cover!
Oh, that's fine.
guys apparently that was what was the cover what what would
a bow
oh this fight is so fucking troll here it comes i will tempt
a team only this fight is so true this fight is actually
This troll is...
This fight is so troll.
This fight is actually so troll.
Oh my god.
My, my.
Aren't we popular?
Sweet.
Good girl.
It's time to end that orny.
Oh my god.
It's supposed to be fine.
Quite clever.
samurai oh
all right I gotta hate this so much oh my god it's fucking
question meet your executioners
How the fuck was I supposed to know Like we're enjoy where's
covered where's dear here
Oh my god with only vision.
Oh my god with only vision
Oh my i'm Okay.
I had this ugly fight.
Here it comes.
Fuck off.
Actually fuck off.
Oh my god.
Fuck you.
Actually fuck you.
No, that wasn't.
surprise okay you still don't know your place well where's
the show rock where's the big rock
i swear to god i okay wait what all right all right twist
and turn all right how about
oh my god i got him i got her i
again already oh my god i'm trying oh my god oh my god die
oh my god i have feelings not even over hearts in the
heavens haven't i suffered enough i wish you'd at least tell
me oh thank god there's no phase three there's no phase
three thank god thank god all the items i've saved was this
to me
was such a nice name i do so miss people calling me that too
fair it seems like an easy fight but i was just not ready
for I like you know how like the game has made me do so many
other things and when she's princess kagoya oh my god that's
kagoya what happened to it she turned in so what happened
when she turned into a hag this what's a plan without a
backup anyway No.
Musashi.
Whatever she is.
Whatever she's planning, I don't give a damn.
We'll just beat her again.
My girlfriend turned into a moon.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Like, I know it should be...
It is an easy fight the moment everything clicked to me.
But I didn't know the gimmicks.
Because it was such a gimmicky boss.
So I wasn't aware of, like...
what her util kit was until like i died like i hit several
times it's time to kill my moon girlfriend yeah doko is
wounded and on the run your sine remains behind the only
gate
so none of them can make a move on us we're winning
Perhaps but winning isn't one Masashi if you have unfinished
business now is the time Yeah
goddesses Oh, I'm just glad it's winning isn't one.
I'm just glad all right We're up against I guess we can't be
too careful.
All right We should speak with Takamura all right the point
of no we're almost at the point of no return.
I don't need extra quest okay we have a bunch of extra
quests at least okay all right at least let's just love
level up some stuff I'm just glad I was thinking I'm so
whoops that's not what I wanted to do whoops all right let's
grab the extra quest so at least I can get final upgrades
yeah oh the fucking two back-to-back rage inducing boss
fights Where are the quest givers?
Alright, quest givers.
Hello?
There you are.
You're the warrior got rid of that giant monster at
Gojo-Osashi Bridge, right?
Give me a favor, will you?
I've been looking for you all over the city.
Those that died that fateful day were buried, but still
cannot find peace.
The graveyard has been overrun by a horde of monsters.
We need to get rid of them, and I just know that you're the
man for the job.
easy chasing a few gem out of the graveyard isn't even worth
comparing a fighting bank guy let's go oh whatever i'll deal
with them so don't worry all right got this one and i'll
grab this one all right where's the other quest giver oh and
yes many uh when as much loot as possible hello samurai if i
may I'm a devotee of Lady Murasaki and an amateur poet.
There, night, I was a mire in the moon at Arashiyama.
But all of a sudden, some ghastly monster...
Oh, no, it's...
Oh, my...
Oh, I fucking know.
But when they said some ghastly Gamma started to float, oh,
I know exactly what fucking quest this is.
Yeah, we're not doing our...
actually shit i'm so done with that one you're musashi i can
tell from that gauntlet on your arm you're all right you
look kind of pale about that oh you see i was helping myself
some offerings over at uh trying to ghost appear it's tough
looking oh my god oh my oh my i don't even okay where is
this all right let's all right all right let us all right
i'll do the treasure one the treasure one's fine treasure
one's fine i just hate the archer missions i think they're
very annoying in general i do not enjoy doing this
i just think that one is particularly annoying
it's on top of the tower all right that's good to know
way oh all
right time to fight them here I guess is it close yeah they
closed the door I have opened this door before they closed
it again oh hey did I remember closing that door or opening
it and unscathed a remarkable feat it was wasn't that good.
All right, where are they?
Where are the monsters?
All right, get over here.
All right, oh my god, hey, hey, hey.
All right, guess I'll use my sword.
Where am I?
All right, this is not fair.
That was not fair.
I got camera sifting
All right Only power
Oh my god This is the actual real fucking boss area
That's the worst part
All right Why do I need to do Bird?
I'm gonna do bird.
Bird, bird, bird, bird, bird.
Oh my god, bird, bird.
Bird, bird.
What the fuck?
Why is your eyes still alive?
Oh my god, no, fuck!
Whoops.
Well, at least he's dead.
Beware!
Oh.
There's more of yet.
Alright, get out of here.
Get out of here.
I do not believe that's the last one.
There's no...
That was the last one?
Okay, before I accidentally get locked onto Bird, I'm gonna
need to swap back to Earth Shatter.
In case it's like, Let's go back to the guy who put us up to
this.
And you go back to shrine.
Then get the only treasure.
Then spend money to get more upgrades.
Oh, no.
How do I get out of here?
Okay, it's this way.
I got lost.
Alright, yeah.
And then grab our last upgrade.
And we go to the point of no return.
I swear to God.
Holy shit.
All right.
Right here.
Time to go to the pagoda.
Audio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let the anger flow.
Wrong franchise.
I would get her ass.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And I did.
her ass to here?
Oh no, it's up here.
And she did.
She proceeded to get her ass.
It's up here.
I don't even know how to get up there.
Honestly.
Oh my god, that blue one tanked it.
The other blue Did it, though.
I feel like the other blues were weak as hell.
How the fuck do I get up there?
There's no ladder?
Oh, guys, there's a ladder.
Guys, I don't understand.
There's no ladder anymore.
Alright, well, thank God there is one, I guess.
Oh my god, climb, climb, climb.
all right
what the fuck man oh shit this guy doesn't even he's not
even self-aware but what the fuck's going on oh shit
all right there we go
what where is it oh there it is if i jump down will i die
huh not bad no sense letting this go to waste okay i think
it make that oh okay like yeah the game was like don't do it
you have so much to live for all right never mind i feel
like i should be allowed to you know at least i can just
drop off the ladder so not to climb all of it all of it Wee!
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Invisible wall saves lives.
It really does.
I was so ready to take the jump.
Could buy Iron temper.
Iron.
Do I have enough?
I don't.
I'll just buy it for now.
I don't...
Guys, I really...
don't want to farm i i'm not gonna farm
wait actually i need to give my mission back first does he
give iron oh he does okay i just have to buy iron then i
have to buy temper iron thank god
where's the mission guy who was it oh it was him right Yeah.
Yeah.
You did it.
I knew I can trust you.
Pondling the dead can rest in peace.
Not at least my own wife.
She's grateful for what you've done.
I'm certain of it.
I still feel bad about that day.
If I got there sooner, I could have saved more people.
Just they didn't get Uber priority.
Your wife included.
Please, sir, do not allow yourself to think such things.
I have a new wife right now.
Alright.
As soon as you came what you did, that more lives weren't
lost.
I won't forget it.
And that is shit you.
Alright, nice.
Um.
Alright, now I'll buy more shit.
Okay.
I need two irons.
Because I got temper iron already anyway.
Um.
Yes, I would need some iron, sir.
A wise choice.
That's all the iron now.
Alright.
Yes.
Another sword upgrade.
I don't think I can afford any more upgrades now.
Oh, I can...
I'm upgraded my outfit.
Oh, I did.
Okay, I just...
I don't know.
I like the gold.
I think the gold is fancy.
I personally like the gold more.
Alright.
what is it we're end game now we're going in end game we've
got every upgrade possible all right here we go we're ready
it's end game time I'm storing it here along with his arm
why do we need his arm couldn't get the damn thing off it
the gauntlet is probably trying to rebuild him from that arm
out well it won't work of course that's not fair I thought I
get to use it what's all that noise it doesn't sound good
I'll go take a look all right what's going on we've got
trouble Takamura Genma have appeared in Rendino and the
Shogun sent soldiers to deal with them What?
Sending human soldiers against the Genma.
Oh, that's fucked.
I told them a thousand times not to meddle with the Genma.
Hey, it's natural selection though.
Probably trying to make a name for himself.
I mean, hey, it's natural selection at that point.
You know?
Sometimes you can't save stupid.
It's just... sometimes that's just life.
If it means we're weeding out the idiots, maybe that's the
risk we're willing to take.
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's the big boy.
Oh, he's back.
How did he fight him?
Oh, don't tell me.
Tell me he's a boss, Rush.
Come on.
I already killed him.
Don't make me fight him again.
Benkei please be cutscene please be a cutscene kill please
be a cutscene fight what will you lose to me this time you
won't survive it oh I have feelings not cutscene fight oh
it's he's gonna continue right okay you want my sword to
just try and take it Guys, I don't think...
Guys, I don't think that was a cutscene fight yet.
I've got more where that came from.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Stop!
That's it!
Don't give them an opening!
Another new sword huh?
Alright.
What's it do?
What the fuck?
You're the hope for this world.
It's over.
What is said that you're gone.
Alright.
Oh, I can grab that apparently!
Esen!
That's fucking right, get Ethan!
Headshot!
Only one left.
There's no escape.
Oh, I swear to God, feeling it's gonna be a fucking boss
rush.
Okay,
that's fine.
I'm fine with that.
Don't allow him to fire that thing.
Oh.
No!
I was trying to...
I had to...
No!
Okay.
I didn't have to get my hand on my keyboard, my mouse.
I wasn't ready for that.
It's not fair.
okay that was like not fair enough frame of yours all for
show all right there you well seen there you go let's do
this oh spamming it and spamming it I'm spamming it is that
okay there's one know what my items are to share all right
five oh there you go oh first try oh my god it's never
seriously
That's it for your armor.
Now say steal.
Alright, X.
X!
Headshot!
Oh, that was not a headshot.
It's fine.
I need a headshot.
Okay, that's bullshit.
That's actually bullshit.
all right if this is part of your sin is planned but
strength alone does not ensure victory all right it's fine
first we have to sort out this walking armory all right
What?
Okay, that was a fucking deflect, bitch.
Don't just stand there.
Fight.
Yes, I got it.
Thank God.
Okay, I got the fucking iframes there.
Get the headshot, get the headshot.
You got aim the head.
Go, you got aim the head.
Jesus Christ, how much Jess is so fucking tanky.
It's actually annoying.
How tanky this guy is.
Oh my god.
There you go.
Alright.
One, two, three.
Okay, I got the deflect.
Okay.
all right are
you kidding me oh okay okay i need to heal i need to heal
though i need to heal all right one two oh finish him nice
oh hell yeah i'll see you in hell i guess bye See you in
hell, Banke.
Shizuka, how's Rokudo Chinnoji?
Something is off.
I sense...
Wait.
What?
This is...
Sasaki Gambu.
What?
Oh, no, no.
No.
What the hell is going on?
No, I died.
No.
Don't put me back.
I can't.
I can't kill, I can't do this again.
He always comes back.
Boss Rush time, Doki.
It's Boss Rush.
Ooh,
yow, he continues.
Oh, he's so cool.
There you go.
He's so fucking cool.
I wish he'd help me.
He would have given me a dire dive.
If only he was there before.
Oh shit she's still alive He can just do that Oh it takes me
fucking 800 slashes He does it in two God you You're all of
my soul if you must.
Oh, no.
Don't.
Girl, you deserve so much better, girl.
She deserves so broke, girl.
You...
Leave him!
You're way out of his...
You're like...
He's way out of your...
Wait, no.
Your way of his league.
Yeah.
Wait, is he good now?
Okoni?
Wait, did he see that?
Wait, is there so...
Just like you always wanted.
It's all yours now.
Wait, no, but you're so strong!
Oh wait, is he good now?
Put that back on, old man.
There's no sport in fighting humans.
make me laugh child i don't need a gauntlet to crush the
likes of you
oh crazy old bastard oh he's like he's dead Huh?
She okay?
Oh!
Her soul hasn't returned just yet.
Shall I take a message?
You all made this far too easy.
Oh!
Oh
Oh No Musashi Just put the gauntlet back on Just put it back
on Oh I fucking called it I called it I was like you're
gonna kill him off isn't he I was like oh yeah I fucking
called it part one I part one I fucking knew he was gonna
die I told you boy I fucking I I so obvious the fucking um
mentor man mentor guy dies every time 700 years of suffering
and i loved every damn minute of it or a farm to his death
that's that's free money right there
You can finally rest now.
And we're farming till the end.
I fucking called in the part one, too.
Bro, enough.
Oh, my God.
What a death.
Oh, my.
And he lets him.
What does a man have to do to earn a death like that?
Anybody takes the souls to.
the sword!
Rather you than him, bro!
My money!
And we forgot to do the suck again.
Well, there's no one guarding the portal anymore.
Now that he's dead.
And he has the soul of the guardian, the gatekeeper.
Oh,
that's beautiful.
That shit is...
That shit's metal.
That goes hard.
Can you, the man of the hour?
I don't think you could have followed my plan any better,
even if I told you what it was.
Here.
You've earned it.
guys i think he's very perfectly sane right he's very
mentally stable intel oh
very yes get so does it's a communication
I'm going to kill you.
I'm going to kill Musashi.
I'll be all that's left.
Peerless.
At the top.
The greatest swordsman to ever live!
That was anticlimactic.
Bro, fucking... What?
That's it?
A huge number of human souls.
Including that of...
Oh no, no, no, Takamura.
Like, fucking really.
Bro got res, his fucking wife fucking sacrifice their body
for him.
He sucks up the old man's soot and just like that, he's got.
Bro job, yeah.
After everything, Bro got revived.
Didn't even last a day.
Was that his head?
God, he got emoted on.
Ashley died for nothing.
Two people died for nothing.
Three people died for nothing there.
Yeah, he farmed so many souls just to feed the bag to Yoshi
himself.
Many thank you for the super chest.
Thank you.
Let's put this world back the way it should be.
In bloody chaos.
Bro actually fucking fed.
Yeah, soul delivery.
Knock, knock.
Yeah, he died because it was your mantra.
That's Yoshitane's castle.
the moment he got out along with it enough malice to blanket
the city where's Takamura Taka um you see he's around he's
just he's in a better place now don't worry about it he's in
a better place I I killed him that was Yoshitsune not you
No, it was 100% right here.
Yeah, she does not believe that.
You might as well tell her the truth.
She did not believe that.
How dare you?
Truth be told, you and Musashi,
caught up in the castle's rice.
The thing that saved us was Takamura's voice.
Aw.
Take Okuni and run, he said.
I'm not making this up.
She's just, she's, she's just wants to dance, though.
all she wants to do is dance wait i'm coming with you i can
fight she has like no training whatsoever by the way like
you have a more important role to play yeah i was gonna say
it like she has no training like like don't people need to
train for years with the sword you've got to protect this
temple like you're actually a liability yeah
yeah she can fight but not with a fucking sword like a
sapphire sword going
she's a speed build I leave the city to you she's literally
a rogue build fuck you the entire city is protected by this
little girl.
I don't even think she's of age.
I imagine you're like, this is always like Powerpuff Girls.
It's like, title drop true.
My city is protected by a 13 year old kid.
Boy.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, I could buy.
Wait, do I have enough?
Wait, I can't even fucking buy anything.
Wait.
Unless...
Oh, yeah, I can.
All right, here we go.
Knock, knock.
All right, how long is the castle part, guys?
He's at the top.
Then that's where we'll go.
Does anyone know how long the castle level is?
All right.
We're about to find out.
No.
Okay, can't be that long.
Yeah, I was gonna say, can't be that long.
Right?
This entire structure seems to detest the power of Fionni.
Alright.
I'm still...
Oh.
Guys, um...
I might not have eaten yet.
Just realized.
Ooh.
I ordered food.
Don't worry.
While the entire cutscene was going, when I was watching
that old man dance, I ordered food because I was like, it's
gonna be a while.
I could tell.
I could tell he was gonna take his time.
Huh?
All right.
Nope,
nope, nope, nope.
I don't care.
Well done.
I will not.
I do not wish to fight you.
Nobody.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Nobody.
Thank you for watching.
We have a good day at work.
Don't worry.
We're going to beat this.
Yeah, I was like, bro, fuck that.
The poor blood at your feet has been transformed with money.
I mean, okay, but where the fuck do I go?
Oh, it's right here.
Oh, I don't like this level design.
Everything just looks the same.
I don't know.
Everything just looks the same to me right now.
Damn, both you and Yoshi got Dragonita.
Broken body with Super Chat thinking, thank you.
part the back-to-back poison swamp really oh no is it the
first boss side the second boss I fought oh I fucking knew
it I fucking it's a oh it's boss rush time I could tell I
heard that sound and I knew it was him I fucking I knew it
was him too i could tell you again thank you hungry for more
oh fuck it
oh he has his face too as well yeah he has a real goddamn
face too as well
are you fucking okay i got it i got it I got it.
There we go.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here!
Really?
Is that all you've got?
Oh my god.
Don't?
Apparently not.
There we go.
Here it comes.
I'm so mad.
I'm actually...
I'm actually so mad.
Oh my god, because I'm fucking course.
A fucking course!
Were you even trying, monster?
I wanna save...
Yeah, I'm gonna save it for a second phase.
There's no reason to use it yet.
Are you kidding me?
There.
There we go.
Jesus Christ!
Here it comes.
Alright.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
Second base.
Are you kidding?
Okay, it's fine.
I got it.
There we go.
That's an easy one.
That has to be an easy one right there.
There we go.
Again!
Got him!
Get out of here!
Really?
Is that all you've got?
Oh, yeah, that's...
Yeah, is that all you got, buddy?
Alright.
Cool guys, don't look.
I swear, I was gonna say, I swear to God, you fucking run.
I swear to God.
Oh, there you go.
Why don't
you...
You gotta do better than that.
That's right.
That's why you level two bust!
oh you really think bro buddy i've it's been 20 years since
i've oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god okay
okay it's fine it's fine okay oh i almost almost spoke that
too i've almost got a little too cocky there But we're fine.
We're okay.
Oh It's a little bit too excited It's this Anna's hall.
Wait, what?
There's something over there.
No, I can't even get there.
Oh Yeah, karma almost got me.
They almost got me there
Welcome, you two.
What do you think of my humble home?
I used GENMA for the building material, if you're curious.
It looks like shit.
It suits you nicely.
It's currently the elevator, right?
It's me.
Don't die before you get here.
up here hmm after killing takamura and gun you see
i'm listening don't worry i am
are we all right ah you killed gun you took takamura's soul
from him i'm what do you know i miss where am i fucking
mecha shit where's my mecha my giant mecha horse Hello?
In the old feudal Japan?
A notion of blood.
How horrific.
Yet another manifestation of his insanity.
Kill him!
Alright, it's fine.
You're in my way.
Still haven't learned.
They still haven't learned anything.
Oh, you're so scared.
I left him for that.
That was one-sided.
Let's keep moving.
That was pretty one-sided.
That was very sad.
Eh.
Maybe?
So now restorative.
It'll be restorative.
All right, apaco.
Apaco.
I wonder if I'm fighting every boss I've encountered so far.
God, I hope...
Oh my god.
I'm trying to remember which one I hated.
I hated all of them, but which one I hate.
Wait?
Oh no.
Hello?
I'm using it.
Fuck this.
I can't.
I will.
use that I can't I actually can't I don't care if there's
another boss fight later I thought I saw something here yeah
they are prepared to fight let's do this oh what the fuck
these guys have so much HP what the fuck I should have just
actually just headshot this all right No 100% worth.
I hate those.
I hate playing those guys the most.
Oh my god.
Alright, get out of here.
Yeah.
Oh my god, did I not got your eyes?
Oh my god, I thought I didn't got your eyes, apparently I
did not.
Oh, good time.
There you go.
I thought I hit both eyes, apparently not.
Whoops.
Oh.
Go up, Doki.
Go up.
Oh, wrong way.
Too far, too far.
Go back, go back.
Eh.
I'm just doing it to build up power-up stuff.
Yeah, I know I don't have to.
By that point, just for power-ups not honestly I'm just
gonna actually I don't trust myself I yeah I was like whoa
whoa my HP's getting a little too low there I gotta I gotta
fucking calm down all right
Nice.
Ooh, iron.
Okay.
Upgrades.
That's good.
That's actually very good for us.
Also, I know if I try to run past, it's not gonna work for
me.
I'll find some way to fuck it up.
Alright, I can enhance.
Alright.
Where are they?
i'm ready oh oh wait i'm not ready oh wait oh no i'm not
ready i'm not ready i lied
oh god i'm so not ready can she fight me in this oh i'm not
ready
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, maybe I am.
Maybe I am ready.
Oh my god, maybe I am!
You don't need that head anyway.
True!
No head?
I'll show you.
Okay, come on.
I didn't realize.
That doesn't count.
It's reaping its axe in my mouth.
There you go.
Okay, I timed it.
Okay, maybe not that, though.
It's over.
It's so good.
Okay, this is okay.
It's okay.
Finally died, huh?
Oh, fucking I'm so...
Oh, what?
I finally moved on.
I think I did.
This is my character, Dark.
I finally moved on.
All right, off we go.
Up we go.
Is there even...
We're just in closest upgraded.
Anyway...
Wait, there is an upgrade below me.
I should upgrade my Easton.
Since I'm...
The only time I use Easton is for the only.
And I feel like it's the only good time to use it.
So I might as well...
Fucking doesn't even matter as the only...
Is there the only upgrade I have for Easton?
It doesn't even matter.
Where the fuck's the hole?
Oh, there it is.
Me own time.
I see what you did there.
Okay, where do I go after that?
Excuse me.
I thought it was like a barrier.
Oh my god, there was one over here, too.
Oh my god.
A fucking course there was.
Um...
I don't even know what to upgrade, honestly.
I might as well.
I have so many Oni stones.
It's crazy.
Powerstone is, like, harder to find.
They upgrade the stone.
Let's do this.
Where?
Oh, my God.
I didn't even see them.
They, like, blended in perfectly.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that was a crap.
I did land it in with the red!
The ashes, I don't know why.
The red overpowered the blue for me.
I got distracted.
You get it, right?
My eyes were up there.
Oh, they were definitely up there.
Oh my god, nice.
Alright, let's fight.
Alright, I mean, where else can I look?
Yeah, that's fucking right.
Get out of here.
But to be fair, where else can you look, but not up?
all right up out go god how many how many floors oh another
boss area all right who am i fighting this tab which bosses
oh how many tigers this is why tigers are endangered exactly
oh my god that's the fucking remember i fight these two
that's what i'm saying This is so easy.
Can't even scratch.
Let's see what I see!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, fuck.
Get ready.
Oh my.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is actually fucking it right now.
Don't give them an opening.
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
All right, that's fine.
All right.
Jesus Christ!
I've tried so hard not to give them an opening right now.
This is so...
He's actually so annoying.
Holy shit.
Bro, bro, bro, bro, bro, bro, bro, bro, bro, bro, bro.
Bro.
Yeah.
Alright.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
I want to go.
Oh my.
Jesus, come on.
I'm trying to fight him!
I don't care!
Bro, stop fucking begging for attention right now.
You'll get your turn!
Oh my god Bro,
I know I know you're begging for attention right now, but
just be patient See there.
I give you I'm giving you attention.
Are you is that what you want?
Yeah
Yeah All right, knock you over
Oh, now you want to use electricity attack.
There you go.
Oh my god, he's so, they're so tanky.
That's what's so annoying.
It's so annoying how tanky they are.
There you go.
Oh, come on!
One more hit!
Get out of here!
They're not hard.
They just take too long, killed.
Oh, these guys take too long.
Alright, next stage.
Alright.
Next boss.
Oh my god, I just got out of a fucking...
I just got out of a boss, but what do you mean?
What?
See you, baby!
I just... I...
We can fight as many times as you want.
I'll still win.
What?
Okay, I thought that...
Okay, whatever.
There you go, at least I got that.
Do your worst!
There's no escape.
I don't know how I feel about fucking boss rushes, man.
The thing is, I don't remember how to fight him.
I actually don't remember how to fight him.
As if you were disgusting enough.
There you go.
Yeah.
All right.
Boom!
Okay, at least he has less armor.
Thank God.
All right.
Oh, he has a face, too, as well!
Stop making a fuss.
Just go down and stay down.
I have to deal with a face.
two later.
He
bought my camera.
I couldn't tell you what...
That's actually bullshit.
I actually got camera blocked there.
Are you serious?
Don't give them an opening.
I swear to God, my beautiful wife.
I'm not trying to.
Alright.
oh that was close oh you almost got oh shit he's got me
never mind
here go
yes oh it doesn't matter too it was like the last hit all
right glad you filled up lightning happy beast Boom!
Oh my god, this is the heirloom end.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh god, that was close.
Do your worst!
No!
I swear to the guy timed it!
Can I give them a note?
Okay, there you go.
okay oh what did I do your worst there you go oh that's
close off you come now get a taste of your own damn yeah
sword okay nice The thing is, I don't even know how many
more...
How many more boss fights we have left?
Oh, he just... Okay, it's fine.
Alright.
No!
Oh, okay!
Oh, alright, alright.
I thought I missed out on it.
I don't even remember how many...
There's so many bosses!
Guys!
Just die!
There.
Another boss down.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
This boss rush is hell.
It's actually hell.
Alright.
Another boss down.
Off we go.
Up, up we go.
Up, up, up.
up up up i'm gonna fight the moon aren't i i'm gonna fight
the moon isn't having a physical form just wonderful they're
gonna make me fight the moon i can feel it i took a piss
recently i'd forgotten how what the about the little shivers
you can we'll see how much you like your physical form when
i put my sword through it in case you've forgotten hell how
unimaginative it hurts so much more when you're carved up
piece by tiny piece oh she's a good note you will too when
i'm done i'll decorate your head with your own entrails and
send it to that little dancer friend of yours a memento to
remember yeah but then you're just trying to revenge right
yeah always tie up those things excited by pissing true Got
him.
What could he possibly want with such a tall castle?
Maybe he's just compensating.
I'll fucking know.
Don't waste your time thinking about it.
It could be compensating.
Once he's dead, it won't matter what he wanted.
God, this is the fucking longest elevator.
Holy shit.
Do you not have floors between, like, 90 and 30?
Like, the rest of it is just an empty fucking lot.
Haven't you got some interesting toys?
Are these meant to be used in battle?
There's like no floors in between?
Oh, it's nice.
Bye.
Wait, I wasted that, actually.
Well done!
Yeah, all empty floors, literally just one in a taller
building.
We can get rid of this guy first.
all right get out of here all right give me the devil it's
it's the wing guy right it's the oh wait oh wait wait not
him i'm gonna do this though fire fire fire i cannot be
bothered dealing with these guys oh i really kept if i have
to i will oh
I should leave this.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to...
That's it.
I'm all...
Oh, that...
No, no, don't eat.
Don't eat.
Don't go.
No, no, don't do it.
Don't do it.
That's what they want.
I'm going to...
Oh, no.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, we can't.
Oh.
Oh my god, he took my ults away.
He took my ults away He took it away Oh my god, okay, okay,
we're fine.
We're safe
Okay All right Okay
Should be fine.
Oh, I knew it.
I knew it.
I knew.
I think God I did.
I think God I didn't alt.
Thank God I didn't alt, guys.
Thank you.
It's actually good I did alt.
Okay.
There we go.
That almost got me, though.
I almost did it.
I had a feeling.
I had a feeling that the wing guy was going to be here, too.
Because there's no other...
There's no other reason.
Oh, thank God.
They called it, too.
There we go.
You're hopeless.
Nice.
Headshot.
How's this?
Oh, it's time.
It's gonna be so fast now.
Here you go.
Oh, fuck, okay.
He was right.
Okay, it's fine.
Okay.
No!
God, it's so fast.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
All right.
Headshot!
Oh, he's so slow!
No!
I expected more.
Okay.
Oh my god, I got it.
Oh my god, I get it!
Eh.
Please, let me kill you!
Rest in peace.
Oh, my god.
It was actually...
I greeted.
I greeted it.
I actually...
I greeted it too.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I was so greedy.
You guys don't understand.
Oh my god.
I was so greedy.
Oh my god, it's all going downhill down!
Alright.
Oh, I'm getting too greedy.
I just really wanted to kill her.
You don't understand.
Oh, my God.
I can't see.
I can't see anything.
Please!
Don't!
Okay.
All right.
Alright.
Wait, I can...
Oh my god, I'm...
I'm fucking on my mess right now.
I'm a mess.
I'm actually a mess right now.
I'm a mess right now.
Oh my god, I'm such a mess!
Don't give them an opening.
I swear to God, I'm not trying to my beautiful wife.
It's just...
Justice!
Okay, you.
You.
Oh, fucking hell.
Really?
Is that all you've got all you've got?
Yeah.
There you go.
I know I started with why.
Okay.
Only time.
What?
All right.
Oh, he said.
He said?
One more!
There you go.
All right.
Get protected, bitch!
Okay, I have to use this one now.
It's over.
I'm going to choke.
I can feel it.
Can you keep up?
There we go.
All right.
Okay.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Headshot!
Oh, this is where I choke, guys.
Be ready.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Okay.
All right,
we got it.
We got it.
We did it.
No greed.
Another boss fight done.
Open up.
Knock, knock.
There's still Tokyo I have to do.
There's still Tokyo left.
Woo!
Still have to fight another moon.
Oh my gosh, it's a long-ass fucking elevator, bro.
Like, bro, this is a waste of man.
Oh.
Alright.
Oh, at least it wasn't.
was it okay at least it was just 10 floors this time that's
the top almost there ah the moon time I would recognize this
disgusting presence anywhere your sin is up there how fat I
am sad just all right
cold shake it off and get ready for battle oh I don't think
I need any more berries I think I'm fine I I think I have
berries for days right now.
Alright, let's check.
Oh, alright.
At least I can upgrade the Oni.
Let's see what we can get rid of.
Okay, greatly increases.
Alright.
Sure, I'll save just for.
you guys i'll save all right i'm gonna get water before we
fucking go to bot is there like time out period any water
i'll be right back
oh i'm back oh my god okay here we go
and spend my so you start a fight with foam and then restock
at the mirror oh that's true i should do that actually um i
should actually that's smart i'll do that i'll do that
whoops oh yeah all right is there purples in here okay
there's no purples in here guys i thought there'd be purples
in these i guess not Now I don't need a revive.
That's pussy shit.
I don't need second life.
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
Whoops.
I did not mean to press that.
Oh.
Like it.
All right, up we go.
Up, up, up, up, up, up,
up.
My earth shatters on there.
Oh, I'm just hoping maybe I'll get the purple.
I'll get like, uh, bony gauge with the armor break.
Get the fucking moon.
All right, time to fight the moon.
Come on.
Oh, that's a big sage.
It's not the moon.
My two favorite people.
What's this?
From this height, heaven and earth look oh so similar.
If I were to shit from here, which do you think it would
land on?
Oh, is the moon the final boss?
this where's the moon thank you truly thank you to think
that you would follow my plans so faithfully we were trying
to stop you and in doing so you played right into my hand
processing like i said earlier with the power of yoni within
me The human souls Ganyu collected, and the Genma souls
you've collected.
I shall become a perfect balance of human, Oni, and Genma,
the peerless being of unparalleled power.
What the fuck?
What do you intend to do after that?
painted all red you seek to unravel the very fabric of
reality guys I think he might be a little crazy guys I don't
know but he might be insane guys we might have to kill him
you still have sorry but I think we might have to kill him
guys easily done I started thinking might be a bad Guy.
We'll see about that.
A jewel with a legendary Minamoto no Yoshitsune.
I live my life by the sword.
How can I pass up a chance like this?
Oh shit, the fight of the century.
You're between two Onimusa.
Let us begin.
Oh, he has three phases.
He has three phases!
what the fuck was his fate always has and always shall oh my
god what a every round be immortal damned or divine all goes
and oh my god he had that was actual fate holy shit hmm
the fun's only just begun
got a bad workout a
duel between two and elusa let us begin this will be fun
Oh, um...
Okay, it's fine.
Alright, it's fine.
What the fuck?
Bro, get in there!
Nicely done.
Okay.
Alright.
Don't give up, Masashi.
The fun's only just begun.
Oh, dear.
Okay.
How unpleasant.
What the fuck?
Alright.
Don't blink now.
I dodged that, I dodged that, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, my god, this guy's, guys, this might
actually be rough.
Sometimes I feel like I'm winning, but the way he does it
with my skill and strategies.
This time, we'll be known.
Are you serious?
the god i won't let it happen we're putting an end to you
let's see you stronger oh the grabs are we know the grabs
are 100 so weird i will yeah no i agree the grabs are really
unpredictable for me i don't want to predict their grabs
very well keep it up
now then
like that's such a weird that's such a weird delete there's
like such a weird holy shit the delay so weird yeah like he
has like a delay sometimes a duel between two Onimusa let it
begin he does not like What?
Oh my god.
The fucking delay.
Yeah,
I know it could be dodged, but like I want to grab care,
like I want to get rid of his stamina.
But sometimes the eating items takes such, it's a lot.
Like upgraded all my items to like, like the speed to eat
it, but I feel, I don't know.
Come on, push harder.
I like the delay when it comes to eating the items.
Jesus.
Okay.
Got you.
A fucking delay.
Gets me every time.
Come now.
Suck it up.
You're weaker than you think.
No, you have to...
There we go.
Not quite deep enough.
No, you don't.
I'm just...
Oh, I was going to try dodging it, but I don't know.
I don't know if it was worth dodging.
I'll take this one.
later hundreds of years ago I upended the mortal world with
my skill and strategies this time will be known are you
serious that doesn't dodge oh I'm just gonna do deflect I'm
just gonna work on I'm just gonna do deflect instead I don't
think it's worth I don't think it's worth like doing dodges
for it
oh my god what is the timing what is the timing to deflect
that no you don't okay okay
figure out the timing oh my god i actually got to grab this
time
there you go
Like, I can't get the timing for this.
Ah!
Come now.
Suck it up.
Like this.
Jesus.
I just don't know.
I suppose I'll take your soul as well.
You can't?
it yeah wait no I've done it before oh it's cuz unless
you're close okay okay that makes sense now oh my god he's
still in okay okay that makes sense I was gonna so be fun
okay all right that's bullshit that's bullshit that's
bullshit and always sound oh my god he's gonna take me in
every round mortal damned or divine all goes in i plan oh my
god just proper souls dude he's gonna take it all
the funds only just begun
rent okay oops um that's awkward
you all right now then okay oh god right in house oh my god
you're so fucking
annoying to fight hundreds of years ago i upended the mortal
world with my skill and strategies this time will be no
different keep talking the fact that he's two more phases
too putting an end to you at least i got that one in okay
i'll take those honestly
those no i
was i was so cocky there okay oh okay i'm gonna grab this
keep it up
Now then
No, you don't What?
So which butt was I even though?
I don't know which butt I was, I used Okay
Oh dear Oh my god, he faded me there
here all right i will win that's
the worst
oh my god if it's hard now it's getting even harder please
do no
no my souls my money my 401k my savings the contents of your
gauntlets I got resulting.
Oh shit.
Resulting.
I am still here.
Okay.
Okay, he has the souls now.
My money.
My retirement.
My soul one game.
Oh, but he didn't let me kill my wife though.
Oh, this does not look good.
Guys, might be a little pretty fat.
At least he made an arena.
Oh, my God.
Oh, he's a lot of farming.
This might be a little bit of a problem.
I don't remember this part, Japanese history.
Enough yammering.
Get down here and fight me.
Oh.
The motivational music, it's kicking in.
Let's end this.
I left you in there on purpose, Shizuka.
After all, you two have been with me.
Oh, please.
It's fitting you die together.
Oh, my God!
Watch closely.
Um, excuse me.
Don't look away now.
what am i supposed to do i'll perforate you i will cut you
here i am oh my god fight back don't keep fighting back i
think you can keep her no charge Oh my god, I swear I'm-
Shall we take a break?
Yes, please.
Holy shit.
He's so fast.
There's no way out.
You die as planned.
A duel between two animations.
Let us be here.
Oh, this is bad.
Take this.
Oh, this is...
All goes as I will it.
Always has and always shall.
In every realm, be it mortals damned or devised.
Oh, no.
I watched a 20-minute cutscene.
The fun's only just begun.
Oh no.
Oh my god, I didn't remember what button I used.
Silly boy.
Let's just take me.
Fine form.
This is evil.
This is actually evil.
This is so evil.
A duel between two on Emusa.
Let us begin.
Take this.
Okay.
I'm lucky enough.
I actually have.
Okay.
Oh shit.
My food.
Okay.
I should have to lock in.
Don't get caught.
All right.
I'm going non-verbal, guys.
I have to.
This actually is...
This is...
Actually not there.
I think I have to go non-verbal.
How unpleasant.
I'll show you on power condition.
Now is the time.
Use Ascent.
Oh my god.
this oh my god I'm not oh my god I did nothing I did nothing
with my only power I did nothing with my only power
red very good
fine I need to heal it anyway please heal hundreds of years
ago I upended the mortal world with my skill and strength
this time will be no different keep talking she's a gun I
won't let it happen we're Putting an end to you.
Oh, guys.
Don't blink now.
The fucking sun.
The fun's only just begun.
Right in half.
Oh my god, try to dodge that.
Suck it up.
right in half okay no you don't oh my god you're kidding me
that's all about momentum that act isn't fooling me are you
fucking kidding me like this oh my god are you tired already
You're weaker than you think I will.
I only have two heels left, guys.
It's just me looking so hot.
I'm skipping.
I'm not watching this again.
I left you in there on purpose, Shizuka.
After all, you two have been through.
It's fitting you die together.
Not yet.
No luck, hmm?
Oh, holy shit.
Give us a scream.
Oh, my God.
How do I do damage to him?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm wasting my time.
No, I'm fucking...
Oh my god, the guy...
Okay.
Watch closely.
All right.
Genuflect.
You fell for it.
Oh my god, you fucking killed me.
With graceful steps.
oh my god he's so much better he's so much better than me
he's so much better than me
okay okay okay non-verbal between two animosa let us begin
here it comes
here okay
stop that take and start fighting
all right i'll get a good knife this time i don't ever tried
it before maybe it's different this is new
Okay, my turn.
My turn.
Okay, never mind.
Your turn.
Oh, you don't.
Oh, come on.
All goes as I will it.
Always has and always shall.
In every realm, be it mortal, damned or divine.
All goes as I plan.
Oh!
The fun's only just begun.
All right, here we go.
Not quite deep enough.
This doesn't have to dodge that.
There we go.
Hundreds of years ago, I upended the mortal world with my
strength and strength.
Bro, I fucking don't!
This time, it will be known.
Keep talking.
I hate the grabs.
She's a guy and I won't let it happen.
The grab is just fucking with me so much.
it's all about momentum all right if only i could shoot it
with a gun if only i would i would if only guys you think i
wouldn't try that
now then
we may not survive this oh my god she's so right
Oh, this is not fair.
That was actually not fair.
I left you in there on purpose.
I really don't like fighting him.
After all, you two have been through.
It's fitting you died together.
Let's test your reflexes.
I...
All that armor and you still lose.
Oh my god, do nothing.
I see.
Oh my god.
Don't look away now.
Okay.
All right.
Mind your head.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, that's no longer fine.
That's no longer fine, guys.
How?
Oh my god.
just like oh my god he's so annoying a duel between two on
emu sir let us begin fuck this arm no you don't
oh my god all goes as i will it always has and always In
every realm, be it mortal, damned, or divine, all goes as I
plan.
Oh my god, this is fucking...
Oh my god, I forgot.
I forgot.
Get me out of here.
Okay.
It's fine.
That's fine.
A duel between two Onimusa.
Let us begin.
I was gonna say if I don't hit that, I would have been so...
This will be fun.
Oh.
Goes as I will it.
Always has and always shall.
In every round.
be it mortal damned or divine all goes as i planned
okay the fun's only just begun
got you
this so i could charge up interesting choice all right oh my
god the push hard
don't fuck here it comes it's not are you serious i had the
stamina you poor
You must heal quick.
Oh my god.
I...
Did you...
Did you have...
I...
I have a lot of other stuff to worry about right now.
Are you serious?
Hundreds of years ago, I upended a mortal world with my
skill and strategies.
This time, there will be no death.
all right keep talking shizuka and i won't let it happen
we're putting an end to you
nicely done i will win
i left you in there on purpose shizuka after all you two
things it's fitting and die together This ends now.
Such a thrill.
Take this seriously.
Oh, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Things you can keep up.
Ready?
Watch closely.
expire
oh my god that what was that what was that bullshit what was
that bullshit what the fuck was that bullshit don't look
away now oh my god actually well thank you for all your help
a duel between two on emu sir I never did you.
Take this.
Oh, dear.
Don't blink.
Guys, the thing is, I have a lot of work to do, too, because
with the Apex tournament, and I don't know how many hours I
can spend on this guy.
I have to actually fully lock in.
I didn't think he would be this hard.
That's it.
I'm resetting.
I'm going non-verbal.
I have to go full non-verbal.
I didn't actually fully locked in.
I didn't realize this boss.
It's getting fucking me.
Oh my god.
This boss.
This fucking boss.
This will be fun.
I don't understand how I can't deflect that.
Always has and always shall.
In every realm, be it mortals, damned, or divine, all goes
as I plan.
Oh, my God.
The fun's only just begun.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's see who's stronger.
Bird bright.
Good.
Keep it up.
Audie, I need your help.
Now is the time.
Use this then.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's
fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Now then.
How unpleasant.
I left you in there on purpose, Shizuka.
After all you've all been through, it's fitting you die
together.
Now...
Die.
A waste of my time.
Have some arrows.
Off you go!
Don't look away now.
With graceful steps!
Genuflect!
Watch closely.
Did that hurt?
Here I am.
It's fine.
Scurry away.
I won't mind.
Just let them hit you.
What?
Are you still having fun?
Oh, I'm having so much fucking fun.
Don't break that.
Expire.
I will cut you.
You're too slow.
Oh my god.
Think you can keep up?
Now.
Don't look away now.
Did that hurt?
Oh, my god.
Don't blink.
Ready?
What to learn?
I think you can keep her.
What?
closely are you fucking kidding me are you fucking okay okay
okay things you can keep up
there's no way out
oh my god
Okay, whatever, whatever, whatever, whatever, oh, the dodge
didn't dodge
I didn't even mean to just kill me just killing me you don't
Just kill
Don't give up my sassy
I suppose I'll take your soul as well Okay, I was locked in
though.
Oh, right.
I was so locked in there.
Oh, a duel between two on Emusa.
Let us begin.
Here it comes.
Are you... and you remember that's a deflect.
Not Perry.
Always has and always shall.
When it glows red like that.
God got the armor.
Oh,
he's gonna use the red shit now.
The fun's only just begun.
Okay, I fucking...
No, no, you have to go non-verbal.
Nicely done.
Come on, push harder.
First fall.
Got you.
I hate, I hate, I hate how I can't dodge his grabs.
He has like a weird fucking delay.
And it messes with me so much.
suck it up
stupid fucking
oh my god that should be hundreds of years ago I upended the
mortal world with my skill and strategist he's such a troll
he's so annoying he has he's actually so annoying to fight
in general she's a guy and i won't let it happen we're
putting an end to you have some more i need to deflect that
i remember the parry that not deflect now then
i'm not dying oh my god are you fucking kidding Not quite
deep enough.
Saw it coming.
Weak!
I left you in there on purpose, Shizuka.
But after all, you two have been through.
It's fitting that you died together.
It's over.
Give us a scream.
Watch closely.
What the...
Impressive.
Are you kidding me?
With graceful steps.
There you go.
Okay.
Wasted my time.
Oh my god!
I'll perforate you.
Don't blink.
Don't look away now.
Okay.
What oh My god, that's fucking fate don't look away now
Watch close him There you go Caught you I don't have any
souls to scurry away.
I won't mind
What?
This won't go your way.
Let's test your reflexes.
Mind your head.
Expire.
You won't beat me.
I want to waste.
Oh my god.
You bastard.
Watch and learn.
Ready?
A
waste of my time.
Are you serious?
okay
That should have been a hit that should have been a hit that
should have been fucking it Think you can keep her No
Oh my god Oh You're between two on emusa
Take this.
You're weaker than you think.
Silly boy.
I need...
I don't know, but am I doing too early?
I think I'm doing it too early.
I'm doing it fucking too early.
right now.
I think that's my problem.
The fun's only just begun.
Let's see who's stronger.
I know I'm doing it too early.
Just try and stop.
Good.
Keep it up.
Really good.
Like this.
Stop it.
This will be fun.
Yeah.
How are you?
Oh my god.
I left you in there on purpose, Shizuka.
After all, you two have been with me.
It's fitting you die together.
Oh my god.
Every time, every fucking time.
don't know how to dodge that have some arrows especially
when he's like so much faster now
well thank you for all your help
okay okay okay okay okay okay a duel between i've never been
so tilted i've never been so tilted before I just think it's
just there's so much bullshit you know he has so much
bullshit to his kit too that's the worst part like it's not
Stop that thing and start fighting.
Yeah.
Keep it out.
Yeah, I think I hit the most.
No holding back.
Now is the time.
Use his scent.
take this not quite deep enough there's no escape oh I
shouldn't have used that early oh what are they waiting I
left you in there on purpose after all you two have been
through it's fitting you die together
The funds only just begun
Caught you I even I press circle I actually press circle to
That's so bullshit.
It's just so bold.
He's just so fucking Bullshit
Huh I think you can keep up.
I see.
A waste of my time.
Watch closely.
Mind your head.
Don't look away now.
Huh?
a waste now look
here I am oh my god the fucking fake ass god fucking
bullshit that he does
are you still having fun oh yeah I'm so having oh yeah I see
your moves oh yeah it's so fun so fun so fun now what okay
that was a dodge come on your old talk watch closely
I should have followed you to the bottom of hell and made
sure you could never cross out again.
Every step of the way, you have been playing into my hands.
All things past and present go only as I plan them.
Seems you can keep her.
Genuflect.
Once and learn.
I will cut you.
You.
Ready?
A waste of my time.
There's no escape.
I
took your genmus.
It's time we dispensed with the pleasantries Misashi without
unleashing the full power of the Oni.
I do not think your attacks will harm you Damn it.
I don't think I could do this alone.
I better call on the Oni's power How I don't have the only
power I will crush you Oh, that's so bullshit, Tear.
That's actually so billable shit.
Let us steal away his strength and turn it back upon him.
Get ready!
Oh, you're serious.
Oh, you absorb it there!
I didn't know!
Guys, I didn't know!
Try a little harder.
Alright, time to get serious.
Fallen Oni, we're taking Yoshi to the down!
Oh my god, come on.
Fire!
Just die!
Are you serious?
I didn't time that!
Oh, no.
This is for Takamura!
The thing is, the crystals don't even give me only cells,
too.
Use your gauntlet to steal your sinet's strength.
I still can't use the only's full power.
I need to- Get ready!
Okay.
Alright.
I'll crush you.
I didn't realize he was fucking grabbing!
Oh my god, I got confused what she wanted me to do.
Don't look away now.
Charge!
Let's test your reflexes.
Are you ready?
Red!
Watch closely.
all will end you're dead I'm
so mad I'm so mad
you won't beat them
oh I'm not making this perish
I won't work at all on you no use your gauntlet to steal
your tsune's strength what do you mean guide red get ready
mind your head
things you can keep up you don't belong in this world i'm
trying to absorb i couldn't
I swear to God, I was trying.
I will cut you.
Okay, that's actually bullshit.
I will win this.
Just die.
Don't look away now.
Yeah.
Genuflect!
Oh.
Let us steal away his strength and turn it back upon him.
Get ready!
Yostere!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh now he looks so pathetic.
Oh my god, we fight the world.
I just wish I was...
Oh my god.
Should do climb up just to have the highest player jump.
Because if I lock it back in, I was so hard thinking of a
different chest.
oh my god
i've never locked in so high before it was the most i've
locked in that entire game
you removed yourself you removed yourself from the natural
cycle oh finally used two swords there's nowhere left to go
you will simply cease to be
I see.
I did it.
I fucking did it.
And I see they give a super chat thing.
Thank you.
GG, fucking easy.
I'm so happy.
How ironic.
Oh, you know.
did thank you audio thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you supposed to be the beginning
and i did it oh my god i i was so tilted i was i was tempted
to leave this for another day because i was i did not think
it would have taken me this long i don't even know how long
i was doing that but i don't know like his entire play style
just tilted me so hard like i there is much to set break in
hell.
I should not keep Takamura waiting.
I'm not going to see you again, no more.
No, my wife wants to divorce after everything I gave her.
Space thing of the Super Chat, they could thank you.
No, that from the other side of the only gate.
I want, yeah, I want ultimate flow, see.
No, she's got to leave after i did everything she's gonna
leave me on your path to greatness snowy thank you for the
magenta soup but thank you thank you achieve ultimate flow
state with that fine boss yeah i actually went on non-verbal
i had doky amazing job thank you guys thank you never give
up never give up thank you oh thank you for the super chat
space thank you thank you because long distance relationship
sucks guys he has to leave me oh my god i'm so happy
i don't know like i i don't mind the boss fight is hard but
i felt like he was just so bullshit you know like i didn't
like he was just so bullshit like his entire fucking his
entire kit his fucking the fact that i can't do damage on
him i have to just keep getting rid of his stamina bar until
until like something and then like he fucking bluffs too
yeah no he fucking bluffs too like it's not his grabs aren't
even consistent
well thank you for the super chat that you think it's okay
whoops wrong game
No, no, no, no You should see me or new with this my goals
are assured What?
He's back
Oh, yeah, we
Oh, no, no, no I can't do another boss, but I put my
controller down, the controller out of my hands.
I can't do this again.
The controller is now out of my hands.
The ultimate suck.
Oh my god.
That's how it ends.
That's crazy.
I don't know.
It has to be...
Yeah, he's human.
Yeah, he has to be like...
That has to be like...
Our DLC...
That has to be DLC.
That has to be DLC, right?
Yeah, but...
NST, thank you, thank you.
Like, what are we going to do about the fucking moon lady?
Oh, she's still...
She's still coping.
That was fun, though.
That, I really, I...
Okay, I will say, I did not fuck with the poison swamps.
I did not fuck with the last boss.
Like, I was not happy.
leave the last oh my gosh it wasn't the last part was the
hardest part let's just it really was the hardest
are you going after gun view yeah but i still think overall
this game was really fun i think overall the game is really
fun really but it's just
Bro, that knife is like, twice your size.
Oh,
we did it.
We fucking did it, guys.
Oh, yes, dance for me.
Dance for me.
I'm so tired.
We did it.
We did it guys.
We fucking did it.
I'm so proud of us I I I liked it.
I liked this game.
It was I you know, I like Onimusha What I would like I wish
it was a I mean, it was pretty camp.
It did have campy moments, but I did wish it had um I wish
it was just a little bit more campy, you know, like a little
more Onimusha to it But overall I had I liked it.
I really liked the direction they went with Onimusha.
I really like the direction they went with it.
And I really liked...
I really liked the gameplay.
It was...
It's not that hard.
Wait, I swear to God.
Like, the fucking power gap between the final boss and
everything else.
Like...
The power...
Like, I was low-key.
Like, I wasn't...
I was, like, you know, fucking around.
I would say I was...
fucking around you know talking to you guys about playing
and everything so like i'm not like i actually had to go
non-verbal i had the difficulty spike between final boss and
everything else was like like where like did i just fell
asleep and woke up from a coma and then like 20 years past
like what happened like i felt like i just woke up from a
coma 20 years later and i'm still at the same level and
everybody else leveled up except for me i have to go
non-verbal for this fucking fight
gnaru more difficult i found i found yoshi yoshi more
difficult only because like there's just too many he was too
rage baited he was too rage baitable like he was so rage
baiting like i like at least gnaru it's he was fast you know
He was fast, but like Yoshi is like, he was just like, he
was like, he was bluffing.
He had bluffs.
I can't do any damage to him.
I had to make sure I had to deplete his stamina to do
damage.
Like, what the, and then like, I have to be super close to
him to deflect.
Like, oh my gosh, there's just so much.
Like, Ganyu, like, at least it was easier to predict versus
Yoshi.
I hate the fake, I hate the fake grabs.
I feel like Ganru, I always messed up.
The thing that I messed the most was just to grab, honest.
Not to grab.
It was, oh no, I think like, he was just fast.
He was fast, but he wasn't like, bullshit.
It's pretty off to Easton.
Well, I'm very bad at Easton.
Oh.
All right, I'm gonna grab my food.
Apparently there's an ending.
I'm gonna grab my food, I'll give it back.
Can't wait for tomorrow's patch where they nerfed the fight
and removed habits.
Ooh, they better go.
Better not.
You know, to commemorate beating this game, I actually got
skewers.
I got Japanese skewers.
So, and Ramune.
Um...
I'm just happy it's over.
I did not want to do another part just for this boss, but I
really did not want to do it.
I...
I was tempted because, like I said, I had, like, not a lot
of time.
I had a lot of work stuff to do.
So I was tempted, but I'm glad.
Oh, I didn't have to.
That was my Ramune.
in.
Hmm.
Thank God.
Thank God I just had to go out there.
God.
I was not having it any other way.
I, this is my first meal of the day, by the way.
I didn't...
I just wasn't hungry.
I woke.
I had so much stuff to dude and I wasn't hungry.
I know it's not healthy.
But I was just...
It was just so much stuff to do.
Mom.
It was just today.
Hmm.
I know.
It's 11 p.m.
God.
I was just so... I was so stressed out.
I don't know.
I was really stressed out today.
It's okay.
I'm eating now.
Me eating now, guys.
Don't worry.
I don't know.
I don't snack at all.
I'm just not a snacker.
I'm just...
I don't know.
I just don't...
I don't mind.
He's not a fan of, like, snacking in general.
for me like what I eat I just eat like treats I have treats
but I don't eat like chips or anything like
I have like chocolate like I'm in chocolate right now but I
I have like um oh what is it called like the Japanese um
chocolate biscuits I have those right now I need like one if
I'm like feeling if I just feel craving for it I don't snack
in general
Oh, hey dad.
I used to do two meals a day.
I just, today I woke up late because I went to bed late.
Wait, it was no, no.
I went to bed at like 11.
Um, what was it?
10?
I forgot.
It was 10 or 11 because I had to do the apex stuff and a lot
of other stuff down the scenes.
Hmm.
No.
This is not the enemy.
Rise up from my despair.
With a will, there's a way someday.
Yeah?
No!
I am a fading flame.
Darkness can hide.
Hide my past.
this way the song is beautiful though time is eating I start
eating I was like oh wow I was hungry holy shit I was hungry
hungry I was just That was my score.
I think Capcom has been like bangers after bangers after
bangers lately.
I think they're on a generational, they're on a generational
run right now.
I'm on.
They released like so many hits lately.
For sure this year.
They're on a roll.
They've been killing it.
They know about Sony though.
Okay,
they've been doing really, really well.
There's still so many releases too coming in.
Actually, how is the new Silent Hill game anyway?
It's not like I'm going to play.
I'm just curious.
I'm curious about the reviews for that game.
I wonder how it's doing.
I didn't have to walk through.
dad later.
It looks good.
I mean, that's good if it's really easy.
Um, are going well.
Because people were like, I guess, like, I feel like I
didn't hear much about it for, like, I don't hear.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, shit.
Where's Emma?
Oh, my God.
She knows how to use the sword now.
Okay.
maybe not okay she definitely does not have the upper body
strength for this sword like she really needs a smaller
sword guys
hey don't don't you the godly gives her a lot yeah that's
her with a lot of strength and she's still struggling with
the fucking sword
my hero how it's done.
I mean, at least he's teaching her.
People are dying right now.
People are dying and they're like, um, they're like
bantering.
Never a moment's peace, huh?
There it is.
That's life.
You got to learn to love the challenge.
I mean, I I assume he was gonna keep it.
Like, that's how the story goes.
That's how usually, they're like, I don't want this on me.
And then later on, um, later on, they, like, they grew into
it.
What the fuck?
Oh, F it was Tyro, Koon.
Beach, give me that says, especially.
Carnage.
Yeah, no, I'm good.
Here's my whimsy.
True.
You can
return to the...
Oh.
So I'm like back here.
That's interesting.
You need something?
And you are just now being changed for Red Souls.
Oh!
So it's like I can restart.
I can redo the whole thing again.
It's like nothing happened.
Alright, let's see what it looks like.
guys fine fine let's what the fuck is that okay oh my god
there's like a little monkey in front of me too oh that's
silly okay i like that i like i wish that was i wish that
was a a pre-order bonus i would have put this on i actually
no i wouldn't because like i like this facial expression
expressions in the game.
I wouldn't want to cover it up.
Alright, we're gonna call it here, guys.
I need to go not do it.
Go back to working on the Apex stuff, but thank you everyone
for watching.
We completed another game.
We completed only Musha.
Um, remember playthrough?
Uh, wait, I can take it off, really?
But it's not the same, though.
That...
It's not the same, I feel.
I feel.
I feel the panda, the panda head adds the most to it you
know it adds everything to the outfit it's funny too there's
a little silly way what does that look like yeah i think
everybody for watch oh my god what the fuck is up what the
fuck is on me yeah the panda head stays on but yeah thank
you everybody for watching i still have lots of work to do
guys unfortunately so um but I, of course, had a great time
streaming for you guys.
I'm going to be going back to work on...
I'm going to...
Back to work on...
On...
Let's see.
Alright, sorry, I had some messages and stuff.
But anyway, I'll be going back to work with stuff.
And...
going to do work stuff now and uh as always everybody so i
had i came back and had so many messages of work stuff so uh
and as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up
and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up
for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys
next time everybody uh bye guys bye yeah the moment i
finished like the and i like tap back to my discord i got
like 20 messages and i was like okay okay okay all right bye
everyone bye